[inaudible] recording.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by the flashlight.
If you go to Joe rogan.net,
click on the link for the fleshlight and enter in the code named Rogan.
You will get 15% off the number one sex toy for men.
Cue the obligatory music,
Brian.
Of course.
I just can't stop thinking of that flashlight though,
right?
If I can throw good experience,
the music's totally unnecessary,
but but necessary at the same time.
Anthony Bordain is with us.
Ladies and gentlemen,
thank you very much for coming by,
man.
This is cool as fuck.
Oh No,
I'm happy to be here.
I was.
I would look forward to this.
Me Too,
man.
If somebody had told me that my favorite show of you came up to me like 10 years
ago,
I said in 10 years your favorite show is going to be about a dude who eats in
different places.
I would have told you to go fuck yourself.
How does head,
that's the most retarded show I've ever heard in my life.
If you told me 10 years ago that I'd be on television,
I would have said the same thing.
Yeah.
That's one of the cool things about you men.
You're,
I wouldn't say you're reluctant,
but we're almost like an accidental celebrity.
Like you just got your book kitchen confidential,
just fucking took off and then all of a sudden you're this famous guy like
getting my Choate.
Yeah.
It was like an overnight thing for sure.
One minute.
I'm standing next to the deep fryer in the next,
uh,
you know what?
I'm selling books and,
and you don't want an RTV.
I mean,
literally,
I think it was 44 years old.
Wow.
That's fucking wild.
I was not looking at anything.
I had no higher ambition than it keep cooking where I was cooking really.
And maybe hopefully have the,
you know,
I wanted some kind of minor,
I wanted to earn my advanced back on the book.
That was my highest hope and it all turned out real good.
That's fucking nuts.
What a crazy story.
It's very interesting because it's very rare that someone gets to live a full
and intense anonymous life.
And then all of a sudden be thrust into the public consciousness.
But actually it's interesting,
you know,
it happened late at night.
I guess I've been in the restaurant business for a long time.
I think I,
my,
you know,
the level of bullshit that I can sort of live with in my life on a day to day
basis,
uh,
um,
is pretty minimal now.
So I was just,
I,
you know,
I came at the television and everything else,
always with the attitude that hey,
I could be packed next to the deep fryer tomorrow,
so I'm just not taking it that seriously.
It's amazing though.
I mean it's,
it's reality television in your case actually worked.
It's like there's people that become famous and you go,
what the fuck is going on?
I don't even know what Kim Kardashians voice sounds like.
I literally don't know what it sounds like.
I don't think I've ever heard her talk once,
but it's,
it's terrible here.
I know she is,
but she,
it's become like,
she's become a show.
She's become a thing,
an item or a program,
the Kim Kardashians program.
But in your case it actually worked.
Like they actually have.
Yeah Dude.
It in a lot of ways though.
I think there's,
there's some similarities unfortunately.
I mean both,
both shows mine and the Kardashians are really,
you know,
my show is about me and Mo and,
and having and
uh,
and,
and taking advantage of the situation and it in that way I probably got
something good common or dashes.
Yeah,
you say that,
but you're sort of almost a self deprecating thing.
Like you're discounting all the different things in the way you're pointing out
all these different things in these places you visit.
Cause that's what makes the show unique.
It's not just that you are in these exotic places eating these crazy fish in
Brazil.
It's,
it's,
you know,
you somehow or another,
they let us show on the air where they didn't fuck with it and they let the one
voice come through it.
I've been really,
really lucky.
It's,
it's,
we've been a freakish anomaly first on food network for two years and for going
on eight years now.
I'm a no reservations on travel.
Um,
it's been an amazing run because at every point,
both networks for whatever period of time I was,
I've been with w w w with them,
they've let me do whatever I want.
Um,
they've let us make the show the way we want to make it.
Uh,
do really fucked up things all the time.
I mean,
it's just the,
there are some episodes are like completely self indulgent and fun to make and
clearly we're having more fun making them then then audiences might have
watching them.
But what shows,
like which would show would you think he did a whole show?
W I mean,
one of the shows I'm proud of stuff is the Rome episode.
We're just sitting around all the shooters,
the,
you know,
the camera people.
That was a great episode count.
Here's how it all started.
The camera people and assistant producers,
me hanging around in some terrible hotel lounge,
probably in Singapore,
Kuala Lumpur or someplace like that.
And we're getting really fucked up on cocktails and you know,
just talking shit the way people do.
And I think one of the camera guy said,
man,
we are so fucking good.
We are so good at what we do though.
I'll bet we could make food porn in black and white.
And we all looked at each other and didn't,
you know,
yeah,
dude,
well let's just do it.
Well,
they let us make that show and we got away with it.
And I'm really,
and we,
I think we did really well.
It's a really pretty show,
but,
but if you,
generally speaking,
I don't know of many other people on television and lucky enough to be able to
go to their,
their network and say,
look,
we're going to do an entire hour of food related television in black and white
and,
uh,
it'll be,
an homage to Italian directors that none of our audience are few of our audience
have seen.
Um,
I wouldn't,
they'll be subtitles who gets a label.
So we're having fun.
And I think if anything makes the show special,
it's that,
um,
it's really first and foremost about me and the crew enjoying what we're doing
both creatively and just having a good time.
And,
uh,
and that's really all we're looking at it.
It comes through.
That's why it's so fun to watch.
It's,
it's so obvious that you guys are having a good time.
When we fail a lot.
I mean there,
there are shows where I'm really miserable and all this terrible humiliating
stuff happens to me.
I don't set out to do that for,
you know,
viewer entertainment.
That's genuinely me having a batter,
you know,
sexually humiliating time.
Like the one time when you were in Brazil and you had a horrible back pain
through the jungle.
Yeah.
Audiences love seeing me in a injured,
basically that's comedy gold.
So some of the shows that have been most fucked up in a bit just been failures
in every,
you know,
where everything went wrong from,
from beginning to end.
I had a miserable time.
It was just one,
you know,
a long week of,
of,
of bribery,
extortion and bullshit.
Sometimes,
you know,
after you go back to New York in the edit,
it put it all together that that ends up being a really funny show.
We did Romania show that made me like I'm public enemy number one in Romania.
It was,
it was a national scandal.
Uh,
but it's a very funny show.
Why was it a national scandal?
It just uh,
presented Romania in a,
in a,
in a comical like that.
They did not appreciate,
you know,
cause we had a really terrible time there.
You know,
everybody was,
we try to shoot stuff naturally,
you know,
we don't,
we don't like things to be set up for us.
And so one of the first rules of the,
of the of the show is wherever we go,
we don't want to see native dancers and indigenous garb,
you know,
some dog and pony show.
We want,
we want to sort of run and gun.
We were foiled in every possible way.
And Romania,
I mean the government and the tourist people just sort of stepped in and we were
supposed to shoot with a humble butcher and his family,
somebody arrived at the humble butchers house beforehand,
said your house is not pretty enough for America television.
We're moving into a like a more attractive looking farm.
And by the way,
your,
you know,
your kids are going to dress up in indigenous garb and dance or pretend they're
happy.
So it was this whole eerie,
creepy theatrical.
Oh Wow.
You know,
from beginning to end,
you know,
that's gotta be the biggest trip is that you're going to places that they're
fucking dangerous man.
Like you would the Kurdistan,
I mean,
you go,
you go to the jungles of Brazil.
I mean,
you go deep,
man.
That's a,
that's going to be a weird fucking way to live.
Um,
you know,
I'm just like,
I'm having this late in life childhood.
Uh,
I've gotten to go to all the places that I dreamed about and read about.
You know,
I,
you know,
I love Greg,
grew up reading books about pirates and explorers and so of course,
given the opportunity,
that's pretty much what I'm doing on the show.
Wow.
What a crazy change of life at 44 years of age.
How much did you travel before then?
Almost nothing.
I mean,
I'd been to France a couple of summers as a kid.
Uh,
I'd been to the Caribbean.
That was about it.
I mean,
I,
if,
if always sure of anything at age 44 standing in the kitchen,
it was that I'd never see,
you know,
Saigon or,
or Hong Kong much less,
you know,
I probably had no expectation I'd ever see Rome.
So I'm just,
again,
I'm just kind of living that out and,
and as long as me and the crew,
as long as we're having as much fun as we are,
at least finding ways to make like more and more fucked up television,
as long as we can do that.
Is the crew,
is there any similarities with the career as being like actual kitchen,
like the gang of the case,
like a band,
a band?
It's tour together for really long time and sometimes you,
we rotate out personnel,
but there's a core group and you know,
maybe the bass player go away for a while,
but he'll be back and whoever fills in for him to somebody else that we've
worked with for years,
uh,
around the world.
So,
you know,
we all like each other and,
and,
uh,
and everybody's really,
really good at,
at what they do.
And you know,
that's fun spelling,
you know,
traveling with Pete with camera guys who were really good at their job.
That's a really a,
that's a satisfying thing.
Gets it.
Gets very intimate.
Yeah.
Traveling on the road to get there.
What does it,
what's the number of people you traveled with?
Uh,
with two camera people.
A producer who also carries a camera and I had been an assistant so that say
like forums,
those people.
So we got five and we pick up like local drivers and stuff on the ground
wherever we go.
Wow.
Now how do you coordinate with like a place like Brazil when,
you know,
do you have to get a translator?
Suddenly there's this entire profession of people,
a very strange mix of other professions who've come together and basically the
called fixers.
You know,
you want to shoot,
you want to make a movie in Moscow,
you need a fix or somebody who knows who to what permits you need,
how to arrange them,
you know,
as drivers knows who to bride,
that sort of thing.
Um,
there's one of those everywhere.
Everywhere on earth,
there's somebody who is available to fix for you.
And if not,
we reach out to like bloggers and,
um,
particularly food bloggers in,
in whatever,
because somebody is blogging about food,
whatever city you're talking about in the world.
Chefs,
people who I,
I,
uh,
you know,
the chefs mafia is pretty extensive.
You if you,
if you know you're going to someplace and I dunno a Southeast Asia,
chances are,
you know,
a chef in New York who knows somebody out there.
So there's that.
You know,
you already have friends when you arrive.
That's got to be nice.
But God,
that's gotta be a crazy way to live,
man.
You know?
How often are you on plans?
Um,
I'm traveling about 240 days a year.
either someplace else or in transit.
Shit.
Have you had the frightening,
scary travel,
a airplane,
a ride yet?
Like with the lightning storm and that,
I like turbulence.
I know this is life fucked up,
but I liked her ability to take your belt off and choke yourself while it's
happening.
At this point in my life.
It breaks up the day,
you know,
really,
and like lay in there,
especially after a couple of glasses of whiskey or something,
you know,
you hit turbulence and you see everybody else in the cabinet freaking out.
You kind of,
it's,
it's more entertaining than the inflight movie.
Uh,
and it does break up the,
the sort of soul sucking a monotony of,
of,
of too long and it in a plane
and it's the best iPhone video too.
You said always have your iPhone video of ready to go for things like that when
that people freak out on the plane.
Right.
I've been doing it lately.
I never thought of it before in there recently.
Every time I,
something crazy is happening on planes and just watching it,
I've been filming it and I'm going to look good and not really,
it's really hard to Jesus suit.
So it was the two formula and then you post this stuff.
No,
no,
no.
I just collected,
I don't know.
What am I doing with it?
Really
make a five plane passenger and make a 10 best terrified points.
I don't think we should put that energy out there.
Fellow.
Yeah.
Placed their faces with cats.
Tango and it looks like cats or man.
Well if you are not a person of interest to law enforcement will be.
I always film on the plane because then whenever I go on the road with Joe,
I kind of do the same thing.
That kind of what you can do.
You have a camera crew or a gang,
but I pretty much do it for Joe and like so when we're on the road somewhere
like Houston or something like that,
I'm always having cameras.
I'm always filming from even when he doesn't know I'm filming like in the back
of a car or in the back of a plane or,
or when we're at a comedy club.
But it's,
it's weird collecting footage.
It's now become addicted to collecting crazy footage.
Like I feel like I can't just go out and have a good time.
I'm always like,
I got to film this,
I got to film this.
I think I would have some kind of condition.
And you get rid of the condition as the Internet.
You know?
The endless resource of infor entertainment that that is the Internet.
I mean,
I got a real problem.
I can't even go to sleep at night.
I sit in front of the box just clicking buttons.
I just can't stop clicking,
which is like one more documentary.
One more article,
one more Wata fucking hyper Nova.
It's going to kill everything.
Holy Shit.
You know,
one after the other.
It's like,
what were those sounds?
Have you seen those youtube videos of these weird sounds and different cities?
I can wrong.
It's probably horse shit if it's on the news.
If it's on the age of new science on major news sites.
Really?
Yeah.
I'll find it.
I'll try to show you later.
Okay.
Hold on.
So earth is groaning.
What is the scariest place you've
been to so far?
Oh Wow.
I don't know.
Scary.
I mean,
in any country where there's,
there's really no infrastructure or no trustworthy infrastructure,
I mean,
um,
do you worry ever that,
you know,
you become like a target?
Um,
there have been times when we've on the show,
uh,
when we shot in Beirut in the war in 2000,
we got caught up in the conflict.
There was a heightened level of paranoia about that sort of thing then,
but,
uh,
you know,
it was ridiculous in the end.
What happened there?
You got caught up in,
well,
we were there shooting a,
you know,
a happy bay route show,
you're going to open no reservations and uh,
went back to my hotel,
a bait,
you know,
basically there was a border incident with Israel.
Uh,
some Hezbollah had kidnapped him,
Israeli soldiers and basically we got caught up in a war.
I mean,
woke up or went home a,
when are you going to look out the window and there's the airport,
you know,
bursting into flames,
that rockets and stuff coming in and we realize,
you know,
we're not,
we're not getting out anytime soon.
So there was,
of course on the part of the,
you know,
people who,
uh,
security and security guys who got involved with trying to get us out of the
country.
Yeah.
We had to think about all of that sort of,
you know,
possible targets sort of stuff.
Again,
it's uh,
it's silly and I don't think any of us took it.
Took it,
took it seriously ever.
I mean,
who,
who would target,
you know,
host of it.
Shit.
Little travel show.
Yeah.
I think some people in some parts of the world and be really desperate.
But um,
so that was the worst situation that you were ever in.
The barrier was a satisfied,
I think the scariest are probably places.
Uh,
Liberia,
uh,
you find yourself where people are desperately poor
and hungry.
Uh,
and,
and there's no law and order at all.
Uh,
you know,
a little situation in a market could turn into a,
a really ugly situation.
Uh,
you know,
those are probably the most realistic threats we've ever,
ever faced.
It just,
you know,
large groups of hungry people behave like hungry people do.
And a,
so there've been some dodgy moments there,
but that's about it.
There's a great online documentary show,
a call,
the vice guide to travel.
Have you ever heard of these guys?
Terrific.
Did you ever see the episode on Srb,
Liberia episode?
He was,
it was a little lurid,
but,
but it wasn't false.
It was,
it was a true picture of,
uh,
you know,
we told the truth about,
about,
uh,
I mean in Liberia for sure.
That's a great way to describe it.
I mean,
they obviously went after the juice,
but I mean,
well,
if you're looking for juice,
you see,
you'll find it.
I mean,
the general,
they think they were with general buck naked.
Yeah.
I thought what?
You don't know who he is.
He's a guy who shoot,
goes into a battle naked except for his boots,
except for his boots.
And he had an egg is killed the enemy's babies.
And he drinks their blood because he thinks it makes him a mortal.
And he's admitted to this.
I mean,
this guy is like music.
It's crazy.
So,
so,
yeah.
And now he's a preacher.
Yeah.
I thought he was in the government,
actually.
It was a preacher.
Now I believe he's a preacher.
Yeah.
Yeah,
Bro.
It's a very surreal,
uh,
it's,
that,
that in many ways the history of that country,
uh,
resembles,
have really bad acid trip.
You know,
Manson ask,
it's a,
they were American slaves that were brought back to Africa.
What was that,
what it was?
Yeah,
but long story short,
uh,
Liberia was,
I'm going to say founded,
but it was,
it,
the nation was created by freed slaves,
part of a back to Africa movement.
Um,
and they arrive,
people essentially who'd been taken from all over Africa,
uh,
you know,
were,
were returned to Liberia,
a country that none of them really had roots in.
And they became sort of an aristocracy and base their country entirely on the
American model in a very red,
white,
and blue.
So it was in many ways,
it's this little America and Africa.
And then things went really,
really bad.
Whoa.
Africa fucking freaks me out.
We're going in a few weeks,
we're going to Mozambique next.
Are you ever going to go to the Congo?
We try every year.
It's like this fantasy for years.
I want to,
I want to do the whole Joseph Conrad,
you know,
a heart of darkness thing.
I'm obsessed with going up the Congo river,
but every time we take a serious look at doing it,
we schedule it every but every year we get the same security reports.
Like no way,
you know?
Yeah.
It's a very,
very volatile place.
You know,
that's where they found that giant chimpanzee.
Do you know about that thing?
Uh,
no.
No.
This is what I want to go.
There's a champ in the Congo.
I mean,
I would never go if you had a force field.
Yeah.
If I had a force field.
Is it champion the Congo called a a Bondo ape.
It's a new champ that they've discovered that nest on the ground like a gorilla.
They Walk Upright.
There are over six feet tall.
They're like 400 pounds.
I don't want to see this van.
[inaudible] kidding me to try for me.
I just remember the locals call them lion killers.
Don't doubt it.
Two different types of chimps.
There's tree beaters,
the regular champs,
and then there's these grey lion killers.
There are real chimp.
You imagine a six foot tall gray Jaguar eating chimpanzee.
They've caught them eating jaguars and there's a real champ that photos of this
fucking thing.
They haven't been able to capture an ally,
but they have photos of,
uh,
some guy shot shot a giant one near an airport up there.
I want one.
Could it,
could I have one working for me?
Like,
I think that's a giant killer.
Chimp in a diaper,
you know,
going out to nightclubs with them.
Like that lady in Connecticut.
But that's what I'm thinking about it.
That's why I monkeys,
especially chimps,
there was no love 3 million in the monkeys because that,
that story,
this giant craze,
like Valium,
he just kicked Valium or something.
There's the monkey and it'd be the champion then like nod somebodies face off,
right?
Yeah.
Oh,
it's like,
just as well,
that's a pretty horrifying story.
Well,
they can just decide to do that at any time too.
I mean,
yeah,
they don't,
but they could just decide to just fuck you up anytime they want and they can,
and it's not even like bad in their culture.
Right.
The culture of Champs,
you're supposed to be fucking each other up.
They do it all day.
Right?
They don't understand our world,
our world of not fucking people up all the time.
They try to keep it together.
I don't want,
I don't want any pet that first vcs,
Abby,
you know,
I do.
Speaking of pets,
if you ever come across any crazy animals or any weird threats like in,
in any places,
like when you go to Brazil and you're in the jungle,
I mean jaguars are like a real threat out there,
right?
The closest a threat for the animal kingdom we've had,
if we were in,
uh,
Ghana I think,
and we,
the idea was we're going to go all the way out in the middle of the nowhere,
this tiny little look I get gain Parker camp and,
and the whole idea was we'd have to get up super early and drive like four hours
and bouncing land rovers in the hope that maybe if we're lucky we're going to
see a herd of elephants and get to shoot.
So we,
we,
we wake up really early in the morning and the camp is infested with,
with elephants,
if it can be infested with elephants.
We were,
they were just everywhere wandering around right outside.
So of course we did what,
what any shooter would do.
You run outside and you'd start to shooting the hell out of these fucking
elephants.
It's a good shot.
Wow.
So we're doing this and we're like,
dude,
okay,
let's get a good shot you and use you closed it on it that way and I'll close it
on it that way we'll,
and we'll basically heard the elephant towards the camera,
right.
At which point the game warden wakes up,
you know,
shows up are guidances step away from the elephant,
like walk slowly backwards.
We've done everything wrong.
We,
these were young male elephants are there.
They are the fastest moving creatures,
I think in the wild once they get going.
Oh.
And uh,
they hate bright like bright shirts,
which of course we were wearing.
Uh,
they don't,
they're spooked by people holding implements.
A,
which of course that's what we were doing.
And they particularly don't like being herded by people.
One,
you know,
thousands their weight or likely likely to charge at any point.
So apparently that was,
we'd come close to doing something fatally stupid.
How will you guys so bold,
stupid is the word.
Were you drunk?
You guys were sober.
We never seen that elephant bashing the guy video that's on the Internet.
That's an important point.
What are you drunk?
Are you so well,
I mean we're certainly drunk and stoned a lot on the show,
but I think now we woke up and,
and we were stone sober first thing in the morning.
Wow.
I mean,
what a cra camera people are really suicidal.
one of our guys,
both of them actually when we were shooting and Curtis down there hanging out
the hatches of these,
uh,
you know,
Russian cargo,
helicopters hatch open,
they're all the way out.
You get in these cross drafts and humps from,
you know,
updrafts where suddenly you're at zero grab,
so you're,
you know,
it's just,
they do crazy shit for a,
for a good shot.
They really don't have a lot of sense.
And it's nothing freaks me out more than those planes with the holes in the bag,
those cargo jets and every sports and Egor movie.
Yeah man,
we've been in everything if it flies or,
or,
or moves on water or we've,
we've,
we've been there.
Wow.
And so over 10 years,
how many different countries have you visited?
I think it's over a hundred.
Wow.
A lot.
So your passport has more than one.
Like my height,
my nest,
Canada,
I'm on my,
I'm in my third passport in it in 10 years.
I think it just,
why they can't even put in any more pages.
And then you got to get a new one.
It seems like you should have a shorter line for security.
I'm really,
I'm really good at you already.
I go into this,
um,
you know,
they talk about how it look.
Cops,
we'll talk about how they can identify,
uh,
an ex con very easily because when they're rousted they relaxed,
they go limp.
They don't get,
they don't,
they will fight back there.
They're trained to sort of deal with,
with that kind of relationship.
Oh,
that's interesting.
Yeah.
I completely forgot my point here.
That's all right.
That's interesting enough.
That's a,
that's a funny point that someone would be used to someone,
someone frisking them.
So I go into that same sort of relaxed.
I'm such,
I'm a professional traveler.
I just sort of relaxed,
go limp and try to blow this out as I go through this really enraging process.
My friend Tony Visa stamp comic from Boston,
he said this to me once,
he was traveling from Boston to New York on a regular basis,
like good three hour drive if you're lucky.
And I said,
I'm like,
how are you doing that?
He goes,
I just go zen when I'm in the car and just goes,
then this is what I'm doing right now.
I don't let it upset airports in particular cause it's futile.
You know,
there's no,
there's shit goes wrong.
You will end up sleeping on the floor.
Uh,
it,
it don't matter how crazy in reserve you get about the situation and you're
still going to end up sleeping on the floor.
Is that what wiggle transit is about?
What is this in transit thing that you're doing?
Well,
I mean,
just you'll learn,
uh,
you learn to adapt.
You're doing it like a new show.
Oh yeah.
The,
it's called a layover.
Layover.
Oh,
I thought it was in transit for some reason.
That's my,
my,
my head.
So what does that show is that it's sort of experiences.
No reservations has always been about sort of me having a good time or trying to
have a good time.
And this one's a more,
we're trying to actually be a little useful,
like provide some information and experiences that you,
you could do,
whereas no reservations,
that's always been a second secondary consideration.
We just,
we do a lot of shit on their reservations that you just can't do their,
uh,
you know,
they're out of rate,
out of reach of,
of anybody's expectations,
I think.
Any reasonable ones.
So this was more about if you're stuck in a place where you find yourself at a
place for like 24 or 46,
48 hours,
um,
it's just,
you know,
good shit to do.
So you filming it,
piggybacking it on no reservations.
So we,
we took a break and a no reservations and went out and shot a whole hell.
A lot of these all in a really short period of time.
I,
it was,
it was actually brutal.
So,
so you're doing two series at the same time then that we broke from another no
reservations,
uh,
bank,
10 episodes of a,
of a lady.
I mean,
you're going like one to another boom to boom.
Yeah.
That's insane.
That's an insane amount of work.
Yeah.
But I mean,
what am I going to do?
It's,
it's a good,
yeah,
take it while it's good.
I mean it's,
this is not a,
this is not a Gig that you can say,
you know,
I just going to take a couple of years off,
go go to an Ashram and find myself that,
but I'll be back
know,
and now I have the best job in the world.
I'd be crazy to,
to,
to dot milk it for everything I can.
Are you still writing at all?
Because I know that you're the one book kitchen confidential.
It's like the Bible and most kitchens and most,
most chefs I know all have that book.
Like every time I go to their house,
I see that book.
Uh,
did you continue to write on the side?
You know,
why you're on planes or,
Yup.
And I'll take some time off to write.
Uh,
but yeah,
every couple of years of the book just did a comic book.
There'll be out next year,
a comic book for a Vertigo.
Yeah.
It's an ultra violent,
a sort of version of,
I don't know what you'd call it,
futuro.
Satirical.
A slaughter fest in a,
in a,
in a sort of a,
a near future where,
where it's all about food.
People kill each other over ingredients and ideology.
Really?
Yeah.
It's really illustrate it.
The art is going to be amazing.
So did you write it or you like cowrote with I co wrote it with a friend of
mine,
a really great writer named Joel rose.
And it's,
uh,
we're kind of describing like Yojimbo or fistful of dollars,
but uh,
but all that chefs,
that's awesome.
That's awesome.
Now who is illustrating it?
A guy named,
uh,
linkedin,
fos and he's terrific,
terrific artists.
How does one come up with the idea to start their own comic book?
Uh,
well we,
we just,
you know,
we sold this concept and,
and uh,
they were interested and they said,
well,
make it happen.
I'm doing it because it's fun.
It's awesome.
You know,
I just,
it's again,
it goes back to the little boy thing.
Yeah.
If you can,
if you could do a comic book,
you know what little boy wouldn't.
Yeah,
no shit.
I used to,
I love comics.
I love comics still.
I had a dream the other day that I went to a comic book store and then I started
getting into collecting comic books and I brought it home and my wife was like,
really?
You're going to,
you're just starting to buy con,
I think I'm gonna buy conflicts again.
Did you ever have to tell you just to commit collection growing up at one point?
Cause I did and I know Dan
well for trucks actually late,
late in life,
you know,
so I knew I was the sensible kid who kept my collection.
So I had a very good comic book collection.
But uh,
you know,
cocaine is a powerful drug.
I've managed to avoid that one.
Yeah.
The one I'm at it,
when I was a kid,
I had a friend whose cousin was selling it for like over a course of one school
year.
He completely changed.
He lost about 15,
20 pounds.
His face got sunken in and him and his girlfriend would just hide in their attic
apartment,
do coke and watch TV.
And I was like,
okay,
whatever the fuck that is the blackout room,
you know,
the foil,
over the windows.
And they got creepy.
It's just very strange.
It was like,
they're like,
they're infected.
That's like they got bit by a vampire or something,
you know,
break.
He was breaking bad.
Does that really well.
Uh,
on that show,
they,
every time they go to like get a meth head,
uh,
apartments,
the set decoration,
they really got that right.
You know,
that shows fucking great.
Yeah.
It's so fun.
Decorating this sets like,
I like Doritos.
I met these people.
Like Doritos is throwing,
I mean,
staining sheets.
Has anybody ever given you shit for shooting animals on the show?
Um,
I mean,
I did.
Peter do not love me,
I'm sure.
Uh,
I mean we do get mail from Vegetarians.
Um,
you know,
I shot a pig the couple of weeks ago on the show.
Yeah,
great episode.
Thank you.
Um,
and you know,
of course people,
people who eat pork,
we're saying,
you know,
there was no need for that.
That was,
you know,
completely offensive and ridiculous that you would do that.
What someone actually said.
I guess you did it for ratings.
Well,
you know,
is there a huge demographic out there?
You know,
I need to see more pigs shot in the brain.
I need to see
more.
I want to see some more animal cruelty.
No,
it was,
we,
we did it because it's part of a process that,
that uh,
uh,
celebratory process,
that tradition.
And I was offered the honor of doing the deed and I thought it would be
hypocritical to not,
you know,
um,
I'm responsible for the death of the pain because we're making a TV show about
a,
about a party where we kill a pig and eat it.
So either somebody else is going to do it or I'm going to do it.
And I just said,
you know,
fuck it.
I'll do it.
You get sick a lot with all the different foods you eat.
Have you ever found any food allergies that you didn't know you had?
That's a,
that's such an important point,
man.
It's,
it's a weird thing that people have where they think that somehow or another,
if you don't kill the animal,
that you're not responsible for its death.
Yes.
You know that you're not somehow or another,
but you just because you don't get your hands dirty and getting the meat at the
supermarket,
you're not responsible.
It's a son fucking thing.
Yeah.
I mean,
I don't make a point of going out there.
I don't want,
you know,
we need some more footage of me looking manly,
she would,
you know,
bring it down a deer.
Um,
it wasn't like we draw,
we try to avoid that.
But on the other hand,
if you're having a,
we've had a lot of animals slaughtered for our meal,
uh,
around the world because that's what they do in a lot of cultures.
You know,
when you were a guest,
it's going to kill the lamb.
Yeah.
So eventually,
uh,
you know,
every once in a while I will actually have to kill it out on myself.
I don't know.
I just,
you know,
I'm not a hunter.
I wouldn't ever hunt for sport for instance.
But,
you know,
I do eat meat and I do eat this stuff and um,
um,
if I'm going to be cool with other people shooting an animal,
I mean,
I may as well do it myself.
I just a the one of the first episodes that I ever saw of your show you,
it's shot a deer in England.
I was terror.
That was,
I was absolutely terrified.
I really like,
my worst fear was,
oh,
I'm going to hit this thing in the stomach or something and you know,
long,
painful,
horrible.
I would have totally freaked out.
Right.
So yeah,
I was,
I felt very,
uh,
was that the first time you ever shot?
So it was the first time I shot anything that big and it was one of the first
episodes that I saw.
It's one of the things that got me hooked on the show cause I was like,
well this is real.
Like you just shot this fucking thing.
And this guy rubbed a,
a blood cross about was Marco Pierre White who was one of my,
was one of my heroes.
Like back when I was cooking,
we'd all stand around in the kitchen and look at a markup,
your whites books in know that is the rock star.
They know that's the guy we all want to be like.
And so suddenly it's 10 years later and mark has taken me out hunting and,
and you know,
I didn't want to fuck it up.
You know,
he's letting his rifle,
here's my heroes.
This Anthony,
that beautiful one there.
He had the head actually mounted for me and uh,
uh,
had the animal certified.
That's a silver medal.
Anthony,
he was very proud of me.
Did you get any rifle lessons or anything before that?
Did you know how to aim a boy scout camp?
You know,
it's really,
I just,
I shoot a lot on the show because there's a lot of,
not just guilt,
it's fun.
I mean when you travel a lot,
who does it standing there,
pop it
off endless rounds of ammunition at a target or something like that.
So we do a lot of target shooting.
Um,
local firearms is something of a,
of a,
of a continuing,
a recurring theme on the show to alcohol.
I mean there's a bar in,
in,
in Cambodia that's really famous that,
that you could basically go to and just get fucked up.
They give you liquor for free,
you pay for ammunition by the round.
I mean that's come on in what society would that not be fine?
Getting really fucked up and shooting targets while drunk with like 50 caliber
machine guns.
Jesus Christ,
parts of the world,
man.
God Damn
is bone marrow.
I still your favorite.
Have you found it?
You like it a lot?
I read somewhere that bone marrow and bread is your favorite meal.
Yeah,
I would like that.
Most of bone marrow.
So to try it sometime it's just smooth.
A little toast.
I've had bone marrow.
I like it.
It's good stuff.
Remember we had that shit in Portland?
Yeah.
As long as you eat fatty though,
right?
Yes.
Mostly fat.
Something.
I Dunno,
I'm in.
It's,
it's very,
I don't know.
It's delicious.
Melts in your mouth.
Cause I,
yeah,
we,
we don't travel nearly as much as you do.
You get in trouble?
I do,
but it's mostly just cities,
city and I mean occasionally I go to the country,
you know,
I do shows in England and we do,
UFC is in England and we always tried to find fogo every city chow.
What is it like having a wife who is a crazy UFC nut?
I've seen some UFC nuts do.
But your wife is over the deep end man.
Jeez.
She trained,
she does Jujitsu and she does Moyie Thai too.
She does weight tie in the mornings and uh,
uh,
grappling and Jujitsu with political Jujitsu at night.
That's a Gracie,
Gracie.
Yeah.
At a,
at his studio.
And she,
it makes her happy and she's really,
really into it.
And um,
you know,
I sort of live in fear.
Actually my greatest fear is that she's just wait,
do you know some overenthusiastic fan?
You know,
some,
some drunk chick with hair extensions is going to step in between the two of us.
You know what,
we're having a drink and my wife's going to choke her out or some shit.
You know,
I'm,
I'm really worried about that.
She's going to hurt somebody one of these days.
Do you think she wants to,
she's spoiling,
isn't she?
I'm,
we're,
we're very,
we're very proud at the board day in household that,
uh,
my wife,
of a couple of months ago choked out her trainer.
He blacked out before he could tap out.
Really?
So she's just fucking nuts for this stuff.
Yeah.
It's all about the grappling,
which,
which it,
you know,
it makes it tough though,
cause we'll go out to dinner like a,
a really nice French restaurant and she'll wear like a low cut gown.
And of course she's got like blue and yellow fingerprints all over giant blue,
which is all very proud of everyone in the restaurants looking at me like you
yeah.
You'd tried dating a kickboxer black eyes and shit walking around bloody noses.
But,
but she,
she,
she loves watching the sport,
but I think a way more she likes taking partner.
Wow.
Well now how long has she been doing this?
But uh,
about four years now.
So you just got hooked four years ago and just dove right in when she does think
she tends to do them in a serious way.
She's very enthusiastic woman.
Yeah,
it was fun.
It was fun watching.
I really love watching people who really enjoy the sport and really appreciate
and understand it.
And then you get to see that,
you know,
like your wife is one of those fucking people that throws her arms.
Oh,
tell her
no.
She's like,
she's a serious UFC fans.
I mean,
I'm,
I'm getting into it entirely because,
because she's in a witness,
you know,
it was a lot of fun.
I was in a boxing fan for sure,
but,
but the,
you know,
this was all new to me,
so I basically,
I have to ask her,
hey,
this guy any good?
Oh yeah.
Once you figure out who's good and who's,
who's interesting and you know,
you watch a few good fights and you understand the rivalries man,
then that is an escapable.
It's just too exciting.
I love the,
I love the Anderson Silva fight recently.
Yeah.
Don't call me.
The whole,
when he put his hands down,
that whole [inaudible] thing was the,
I thought the fight was over there and he just totally got in the other guy's
head.
He was such as contemptuous thing to do.
Well,
he gets his timing.
What happens with Anderson is Anderson,
he's like calculating you.
He's figuring out,
he stepping inside the danger zone and outside and trying to figure out what
your instincts are,
what your reflexes are.
And then he realizes that after like 1520 seconds,
you're going to slow down.
And you know,
like 45 seconds of the first round guys start to slow down,
two minutes,
three minutes in,
and they really start to slow down.
And that's when Anderson starts to pile it on.
He's like calculating your abilities and then he can just get right in front of
you and put his hands down and there's nothing you can do about it.
It's gotta be the most horrifying feeling in the world,
to be locked in a cage with a magician.
You know,
a dude who can hit you and you can't hit him.
And he's very confident and he's locking in on you and you know he's got you
timed and figure it out and then it just starts popping off on you.
That was a really impressive Fido.
He's an amazing athlete,
man.
He's,
he goes down in my book is one of the all time great athletes.
You know,
like the,
the Muhammad Ali's and sugar sugar ray Leonard's and all the Roberto Duran is
all the greats of the past.
I think Anderson Silva goes right in with him,
you know,
obviously different sport,
but did the same thing that,
that,
that super athlete,
that guy that can do things that other people just can't do.
I'm a,
I was a,
you know,
Ali was a personal hero.
You know,
for me,
I just,
uh,
as a,
as a fighter,
as a personality,
as a,
as a leader,
uh,
I just
really looked up to him.
It's still look up to them.
It's very unfortunate what happened to him.
You know what I mean?
You want to talk about a guy who was this incredible speaker who was so fast and
so fluent,
so sharp,
and the we can talk and the way you could break things down and the way he means
his ethics.
He stood up for this fucking Vietnam War and he said,
you know what,
man,
not,
no Vietnamese ever did nothing to me.
I'm not going over there.
Uh,
you know,
I,
I put them up there with like Jefferson and a in Lincoln and,
you know,
I just see him as a really a great,
one of the greatest,
uh,
in most heroic American icons.
I mean,
certainly.
Sure.
Well,
especially around the world.
Respected and looked up to,
uh,
have you seen the film a when we were kings?
Yeah.
It's just amazing.
I cried like a baby at the end of that film every time.
It's amazing film.
Then that's the film where hunter s Thompson was hired to go run and he was so
upset because he was an Ali fan.
He knew Ali was going to get killed,
that he just just took drugs and floated around the pool.
The Nixon mask on and miss the whole fight just get dropped.
Or Thompson a,
another personal hero,
but a mine,
I think I sat or a story then,
you know,
I'll,
I mean,
people say all these happy now really,
so I don't,
you know,
I don't think that Thomson clearly was,
was a happy man.
Thompson was in a long pain too.
You know,
he had a hip replacements and that,
uh,
that's brutally painful for some people.
He had like a lot of physical ailments and on top of that,
his body was just so beaten down from the daily Busan.
I mean,
he just pounded daily,
you know,
obviously,
I mean,
I think anybody who reads my stuff,
you know,
I was,
I am shamelessly,
uh,
student dove or an enthusiast of a hundred times in his early work.
I really,
when that stuff came out in rolling stone,
I remember,
you know,
running to the story to get fear and loathing in Las Vegas serialized,
uh,
life changing.
Yeah.
You know,
but I,
I don't,
that's a guy who,
who sort of peaked early and I think he had a very hard time for the rest of his
career after,
I think probably FEMA loading on the campaign trail.
I think he was,
the guy was clearly struggling with writing for the rest of his life.
Well,
I think you,
you just can't do that to your health and not struggle creatively.
You can't do that.
You can't just poison yourself to cope.
That's for sure.
You can't do cocaine right now.
Maybe two sentences and then will happen.
You'll either keep writing,
it'll be utter and complete shit or you'll find some way to not write it off.
Embarrassingly,
I wasn't,
I didn't know much about hunter s Thompson until I was in Seattle once I was
staying in a hotel room and I had a layover and uh,
I just,
nothing to do just flipping through the paper view movies,
Gonzo life and work life and times of hunters Thompson,
I think it's called.
Yeah,
I watched a documentary on Holy Shit,
you know,
when they show how eat fucking when Ed Muskie was running for president and you
started writing fake stories about the guy being on Ibogaine and bringing it
into exotic
and he made up names for new drugs that,
you know,
a dude was on something called wallet,
some new shoes,
some new form of stuff actually found its way into the straight media,
defend them.
So you gave some homeless guy who's press credentials,
I think his White House credential,
really without some ethics stuff.
But I think,
uh,
he did some,
you get it if you,
if you read some of this stuff,
uh,
in some of the lines and,
fear and loathing in Las Vegas.
It was a very romantic,
sentimental side.
He wrote some beautiful sentences about how his hopes were smashed forever by
what he saw happening politically in this country.
Well,
Nixon,
it,
and just,
you know,
really fucked with Connor Thompson's head.
What was great about his,
his rantings and drug induced,
you know,
his,
just his,
his vision of the world was that he had been through a utopia period in San
Francisco in the late sixties.
So he had this idea of this LSD culture where he knew this was possible.
He knew it could be beautiful.
And then when the hopes were dashed and all the water was thrown on the fire,
then he became this,
you know,
wild fucking renegade.
That line about the,
it's right here.
This is where the wave broke and then it all rolled back.
I think he's talking about the desert near Vegas.
Um,
which was one of the very,
you know,
this was like a failed romantic,
a failed Hippie,
you know,
who's,
who's seen everything go ugly real quick.
Yeah.
And I'd love the way he described the,
so many people that were in the psychedelic movement there was calling them
mental cripples if he's describing it,
that these,
you know,
basically these people are just locked into this crew of losers and they're
dragging them around with them.
And he stepped to the side and he was watching the whole thing crashing against
the rocks.
Such an,
a fascinating writer.
That guy was,
and it was so fascinating that he had this idealistic period when he was younger
and it had the hopes dashed.
So it was almost like,
you know,
I think it's where the anger came from them,
which was also so,
you know,
what was so funny about the Thompson Yeah.
That he describes a bad acid trip once,
I think in,
in uh,
in fear and loathing in Las Vegas where he describes a really bad acid trip as
being one where you've looked at,
I need a leg and see your dead grandmother crawling up your leg with a knife in
her teeth.
That is a beautiful image.
Yeah,
he's one of those dudes.
I really wish I had a chance to meet,
you know,
once you find out about them later in life,
I'm like,
wow.
He was a great letter writer to use.
The letters are available.
I think that books are called the proud highway.
And his correspondence with the people is really hilarious and really,
really fun.
It's a brilliant dude.
Watch that for folks listening.
Watch that documentary though.
Danzo yeah,
whatever it is great.
And works of something.
I don't know if it's the life and times or whatever it is,
but just Gonzo look for it.
It's fucking incredible.
So no one has really ever given you a hard time about killing animals.
Um,
what about from all the shit you say about Vegans,
vegans?
I find that very defensive because I've joked about vegans a few times on the
podcast and I've gotten a bunch of hate mail hate tweets.
Yeah.
Um,
there's there,
there's a hardcore of vegans who are in,
who were,
they're not going to like me anyway,
you know,
whether I shoot animals,
that's the fact that I'm eating meat at all and talking about it as if it's
something that we should all do.
I'm already there.
They're blood enemy,
so I'm not ever really get any problems with them.
It Vegetarians,
I have a surprising number of vegetarian fans,
which is something I really don't understand.
I'm grateful for it.
But apparently there are vegetarians with a sense of humor.
Total vegans tend to not have a sense of humor.
Um,
but no,
they haven't really,
I haven't had any problems.
This a usual angry stuff,
but not a lot of it.
I always wished that somehow or another science and figured out a way to record
the screams of lettuce now that they've found that led us,
they,
they can't move,
but they,
yeah,
they scream like squashing kittens,
you know,
it's just not a microbial level.
We can't really pick it up,
right.
Cause poor lettuce is suffering every time you eat it.
And then see what these self righteous fox think Zuck be or walking in the whole
foods and you're like wearing the scarlet letter if you're just in the whole
foods at the wrong time and there's just vegans everywhere.
I knew down when you're walking down
you don't think it's that bad.
It's not that bad.
It like that.
That would be friends that are vegans.
I have a few silly friends.
I got Jamie Kilstein,
he's a Vegan,
he's a great guy.
I love that dude.
He's silly though.
And yeah,
have you ever been,
should help them if we can.
He used to eat meat and you know,
and now he's like super lefty.
He's like,
he's got this a radio show,
citizen radio,
you know,
and they're real,
real,
super lefty.
He just got to Cook Bacon around them
somewhere in the distance.
Right.
It's got to smell anything.
Be smelling like be around wild pigs.
You know,
if you're so happy about pegs,
if you wouldn't be,
if you saw a feral pigs,
the pigs that you see have no relationship to the pigs that we would have if
they were,
when we talked about this in the last podcast,
that they've transformed,
you know,
wild pigs.
If you set a domestic pig loose within three weeks,
their body starts to change.
They grew,
their tusks grow long,
their snout grows along,
their hair gets shaggy,
and they become more delicious.
Really do that while big as good.
Is Wild pig better than domestic pig?
Kind of.
It depends what you're looking for.
You know,
it's a game ear.
I've had board before.
That's fucking delicious.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
Some of the,
the,
the game needs,
so like the most delicious meats,
like elk,
elk is fantastic.
You're around elk?
No,
never.
Oh,
elk is delicious.
Yeah.
Elk Liver as delicious.
Elk Liver.
Yeah.
What does that,
it's like a calves liver,
but with its own sort of
elkey flavor.
Well,
whoever figured out how to do Fogg wa,
that guy is a bad motherfucker.
And what it's going to be illegal out here,
I think in 2012 flats a laws,
laws kick it in.
It will be,
I believe,
illegal to sell in the state of California.
Oh my God.
Here's a,
there's a restaurant called Brandywine and woodland hills and it's like one of
their specialties and it's fucking fantastic.
It's so good.
And I know it sucks to be a duck,
but it sucks to be a duck no matter what,
when they have a giant liver and not,
yeah,
it'd be on that issue.
People can really tend to get cranky,
especially out here.
I mean,
uh,
some of the animal activists,
you know what I mean?
Absolutely terrorized chef friends of mine up in San Francisco.
Really,
there was a group up there who terrorized a chef friend first,
you know,
threatening phone calls.
Uh,
they broke into his business,
a trashed the whole business,
plugged up the toilets,
you know,
acid on the walls.
But the nicest thing they did,
I thought was they slipped into his backyard while he was away and videotaped
his wife and infant child together from the rear window,
you know,
from the,
from the backyard.
And they sent him the tape.
Holy Shit.
I'm basically saying to stop serving or selling or in any way dealing with Foie
Gras,
you know,
after this,
I just feel compelled,
even if out of spite to eat foie gras for the rest of my life,
you know,
yeah.
I will eat it stands.
There are some cons out there that just waiting for an argument they're waiting
to pick aside to beyond whatever team it is and fucking fight that to the death.
Yeah.
I think they smartly saw four garage and easy when,
you know,
it's not like this is any more outrageous or painful or bad or procedure,
uh,
in,
in any way than any other animal we eat.
I mean,
the way chickens are raised in this country is,
is truly shocking or domestic hogs from some of the major,
uh,
the major houses.
You know,
these are really sort of grotesque mass market.
Uh,
you know,
a very unhealthy way to create food,
let's put it that way.
So there are bigger and more deserving targets and flog raw.
But I think the,
the animal rights guys,
uh,
saw it as something that they could win that would be a high profile.
It looks bad.
Um,
and we should say what it looks like.
You know,
it's,
it is,
uh,
basically when they feed the geese who generally,
if it's any kind of any sort of a quality operation,
the geese or the ducks come over to the feeder.
But basically you tilt the things head back,
you put a long funnel down its throat and put a couple of handfuls of ground
corn in which they readily eat.
It just looks like they're having food jammed in and them.
And if you,
if you play footage of,
you know,
some place in eastern Europe that is mass producing this stuff very cruelly,
there's some really terrifying footage that that makes for a very lurid picture
of the process.
Add to that,
that French,
if you know it's got a French name and only a bunch of uh,
you know,
wealthy high end restaurants serve it,
it was an easy victory for them.
It's their ultimate goal know,
but basically
bolstered by their,
their victory with four gras here.
They will then be able to raise money towards the next victory,
which you know,
ultimately leads to their aim,
which is to give chickens the vote
is in fog.
Why can't you get it organically where you don't force feed them isn't there?
So they say so they,
I mean they will,
they will,
they will if just let left on their own devices during a certain season.
You eat themselves into a bloated liver fattening situation for sure.
But that's the own way to get good fog wise to do that.
That sort of force feeding cause otherwise the liver is just not,
you're not grabbing this any,
anyone I know in this country who sells for ground,
their restaurant buys from one or two or three outfits,
all of which I could tell you or not people brutally grabbing animals and
jamming this tube down her throat and that get us some cartoon cat and me and
one of those old Warner brothers cartoons,
you know,
jam and mouthful after mouthful,
as the belly expands,
it's like two handfuls a day.
It takes two like two seconds and uh,
it's not that bad.
And the animals otherly otherwise live really cool,
comfortable.
Luxury is lives for,
for,
you know,
in the,
in the world of poultry,
uh,
they're the aristocrats so it's really just a couple of quick glass a day and
that's it.
Yeah.
Then like every other animal we kill lemon harvest their stuff and in this case
their stuff has a delicious,
delicious,
smooth,
creamy,
very tasty liver.
I can't wait to try it.
You've never had it.
Now you've got to go to this mega to Dan,
right.
Eat twice as much that I would normally go to this brand new wine place.
So those are the people you'd have to,
you know,
does the people who get angriest,
I think there's some people that love animals more than,
than loved people.
Those people are creepy.
That does those fucking team,
animal people,
those people that want to rescue animals from this.
There's certain people,
their agenda is ultimately to have no animals under people like in yards,
no animals contained,
none.
You don't own animals.
Animals have their own rights.
And that's,
it's such a first world form of lunacy as well.
They believe it's evolution.
They believe that,
you know,
we need to move past our monkey passed and we moved to a need to move past our
carnivorous ways and embrace the ways of the plant.
It's healthier and it's natural.
Annuity has to get hurt and we don't have to have horrific domestic,
but that's who likes to see animals hurt.
I mean,
we could all agree on that.
That's true.
But you know,
if you don't shoot him,
they don't live forever.
Right?
I mean it's just getting silly.
There's a cycle of life.
It's a real simple,
that's shit's good for you.
Stakes or when you work out,
if you work out,
nothing feels better than a steak.
And you slice into that thing and you start chewing it in the blood in your
mouth.
Like,
Oh yeah,
that's,
you know,
this is what you needed.
This is what you're looking for.
I feel that urge often,
but you know,
it's really,
maybe every couple of months I'll get that suddenly,
you know,
I'd really like a salad
maybe every two months.
Or are you actually,
if you're in like the Czech Republic,
anywhere in Eastern Europe,
basically,
uh,
for,
for more than two weeks,
really starting to think,
whoa.
Or Argentina or a gray.
You don't see a green vegetable for like weeks.
Why you see anything?
It's says like pork,
pork,
more pork starch and beer.
Do you start blocking up?
Yeah.
Brock Lesnar,
uh,
our UFC,
a former UFC champion,
he had to get 12 inches of his colon removed because all he ate was meat.
Really?
Yay.
It was one of those crazy dudes who like,
wouldn't eat salads.
He's a fucking caveman,
you know,
he's this giant gorilla.
He's like literally like a real viking.
His fucking head is this big giant wrestler dude.
He's a savage and he just ain't me.
That's all he wanted to eat in.
Want Broccoli.
Fuck you with your Broccoli.
He's just eating steaks and just dropping people in their heads.
Well apparently when you do that you,
if you have just too much protein it can cause something in your stomach called
diverticulitis.
And that's what happened with him.
And ultimately getting it from curriculars,
cucumbers to this,
the seeds,
you know,
anything that that has semi digestible particles.
Like I think I get the seeds and cucumbers for instance,
they see he's in cucumbers can give you diverticulitis.
Yeah,
they,
cause they sort of took off into the side there and it start to irritate this
fat.
It's fascinating.
Turn went whoa.
Conversation.
We're going to move our way on to ulcers in the and then,
oh,
this deal at working of my favorite words,
the only reason I'm bringing up is that,
uh,
you know,
all he did was eat meat.
And I always wonder like,
that can't be good.
You know,
how do these people,
man,
civil,
look,
Jesus,
he's,
he was pissed off before now.
Now he's lost 11 inches of colon.
12 of 12.
Yeah.
He's really pissed off.
Yeah,
no shit.
because you have to eat.
I mean like,
and how do these cultures do it?
How do they get away with just eating meat?
Broccoli?
There's no,
it's to say I think certain cultures clearly over time,
um,
develop their systems around the food.
You'd be,
you see this in the north of Canada with the,
uh,
people up there.
They eat seal and seal fat.
They need it.
They're there.
And their bodies have changed because of this diet to,
to,
to adopt to this incredible coal.
I mean,
it's the notion that people could ever be vegetarian in a place like that where
there's not a growing thing for a thousand miles and it's like 20 below zero.
You know,
these people live because they shoot seals and eat their blubber and you could
see it in their bodies.
They're,
you know,
they're able to withstand temperatures that would kill us in hours.
Jesus Christ,
they also have some weird thing with their fingers.
Don't get numb to have a incredible circulation in their fingers.
They can take extreme cold that we wouldn't be able to take.
It's like one of the things that they point to a adaptation.
It's one of the,
like the key points of adaptations have been observed over.
It's,
it's pretty amazing.
It's pretty amazing,
you know,
especially when you're,
when you feeling it.
I mean,
you know,
when,
when you feel cold like that for the first time,
you,
what's the coldest you've ever been?
That was,
that was,
what is it?
What is the number?
I don't even know.
I know that if,
you know,
stepping outside for a minute in order to have a cigarette,
uh,
you know,
you have to completely suit up.
It just cold.
So penetrating that you really got to just a couple of minutes before you start
getting hypothermic.
I know a dude who knows a dude who lives in Alaska and the guys ACU maker makes
pool cues lives the way the fuck up north.
He took a bucket of hot water and threw it off his back porch and it was frozen
before it hit the ground.
Wrap your head around that shit.
It didn't seem possible.
It is possible apparently.
Apparently it's like 40 50 below zero.
That's what happens.
I remember a up there and we were all in our latest sort of,
you know Everest Ready,
you know down park is,
you know they laughed their asses off at us when,
when we got off,
when we got off the plane when we said,
you know,
are we dressed well enough to go out in the canoes and they just laughed their
asses off.
Had a slip,
a big like Caribou smock over yourself on top of the down jackets to you know,
to,
to operate.
Fuck or all our camera's locked up like froze up and locked up within seconds of
each other after,
I don't know,
it must have been,
maybe we shot for an hour,
an hour and a half.
You know,
machinery can't handle it.
Was that the most humbling,
uh,
feeling of nature that you've ever had while shooting the show?
I'm seeing a whole family,
you know,
basically shoot a seal,
drag it onto their kitchen floor and a tarpaulin and then everybody in the
family,
you know,
mom,
dad,
grandma,
you know,
junior,
they all whip out dies and start tearing this thing apart.
And he started eating little pieces of it too.
They use the whole thing each other and it looks like it looks like night of the
living dead.
But it is in fact when the most sort of genuinely heartwarming times that had on
the show.
I mean,
they're,
they're survivalists.
They mean they're incredibly happy when they're doing this.
Um,
and,
and juxtaposing those,
you know,
those pictures in your mind,
what are clearly a close and happy family,
uh,
having a good time with all of this blood that's kind of takes some getting used
to it.
But I think when you travel a lot,
you get used to,
uh,
the notion that people are different,
you know,
live in very different circumstances and people adapt to those circumstances.
And that's just the way it is for them.
Totally.
And I think it's,
uh,
you know,
because because we're interested principally and food on the show,
I think people everywhere I've been particularly nice to us and let us see a
particularly,
um,
I dunno,
a side of their personalities,
aside of their cultures that are,
I think a lot of other hard journalists don't get to see people's defenses are
down.
You know,
they don't,
they're less likely to put up a front or be someone other than who they really
are.
You know,
over the table.
right away a break bread with somebody,
you drink the local drink,
whatever it is you eat,
whatever's offered.
You try to be a good guest.
I think you're going to connect with people over food in a way that you could.
And if you're just some guy with a microphone and a camera,
people,
cameras and things,
you know,
changes a situation.
Uh,
but the fact that w w a I travel largely on my stomach,
I think is me.
Uh,
uh,
you know,
like I said,
an advantage.
What a fucking crazy when I lived in.
That's fascinating.
We even did you was a Brazil the last USC.
I didn't go to that one.
Yeah,
that was filming fear factor.
So I stayed home.
I couldn't afford to take the four days off.
It's good food down there in Brazil.
Rio,
I've been to South Palo.
I went to a real to Haas Korea and South Paulo.
Pretty bad ass.
Yeah.
Like photo or chow,
but they had a lot more organs in Brazil to eat a lot of chicken hearts and
things along those lines.
Chicken livers.
The big meal is fish water.
The whole country does it.
It was water.
It's,
it's basically a big stew of who's in stouts and black beans and it's really
delicious.
And it's,
it came originally from slave food.
It was the,
the scraps from the table of the wealthy Portuguese that,
uh,
their slaves would collect and try to make into something edible or even
delicious.
And over time they created this dish that,
that uh,
you know,
it was the food of the very poor at one point.
Now it's like the national dish.
Everybody in Brazil at one point or another Saturday invite the family over and
you sit around eating this huge,
huge amounts of fetch water and getting really,
really,
really fucked up on Kinshasa.
W the episode that you had in Brazil was really wild when you were at that fish
market and as he's fucking alien fish that they're all eating that is lucky at
their mean you're,
you know,
that's freshwater fishing or that you're in water,
the depth of a rice patty,
you know,
I mean three feet of water and you'll,
you're driving around and you're looking at basically rice patty deep water to
left DC,
a 500 pound freshwater fish,
you know,
breaking the surface.
It's wild.
I mean there are all of these fishing and creatures and uh,
and,
and fruits and vegetables down there that never make it out of that area.
So it's really a
ingredient wise,
it's really another planet.
Yeah,
I would imagine.
So.
I really,
I,
like I said,
I didn't get to eat much interesting food.
I was there.
I was there for the World Jujitsu championships in 2003 so I was only there for
a couple of days,
but uh,
we did go to the supermarket and get these fucking alien looking fruits.
Like I had never even seen him before.
Never heard of him and no idea what the fuck it was.
I just picked up a bunch of different ones that weird seeds in them and strange
flavors and it's a great country,
great food,
great culture.
It's a wild country.
People are,
people are really nice.
They're the country that figured out fighting.
They figured it out.
There was a lot of confusion as to how to fight correctly.
It's,
the Brazilians were really one of the first to really figure it out.
They put the first big piece to the puzzle.
Jujitsu put the first big piece where everybody was like,
Whoa,
okay,
this,
you got to know this because if you don't know this,
they're going to grab you and they're going to break your shit.
It's really sample.
So the,
the Brazilian guys just revamp the whole system and then wrestlers came along
and kickboxers and then people realize he,
you have to have really a full arsenal of techniques.
But if you don't have a full arsenal of techniques,
if you just had one,
two is probably one of the best ones to have.
And the Brazilians were the ones who figured that out.
Now when it came to,
if you didn't know back in the day,
nobody knew everything cause it never was anything like the ultimate fighting
championship.
So there's never an opportunity to see what was better than,
no,
it was just speculative.
Is it better to be a boxer as a better to be a wrestler?
Who the fuck knows it just nobody really knew.
But the Brazilians came along and they figured out that if you only know one
thing,
he should know how to choke people.
Cause fights usually scramble the,
you know,
you're in a bar,
you fall,
you're on the ground that you should know how to strangle the guy once you go to
the ground.
That's a wild culture to figure that out,
man.
You know,
I love it.
It's,
it's,
you know,
reos.
Awesome.
I like El Salvador Bahia and the in the north,
uh,
that's sort of the African heartland of Brazil and it's where the food is sorta
s spiciest and richest and most interesting.
You know,
it,
it just,
there's no culture like it on earth.
Aside from the fighting.
It is.
I don't know how anyone could actually,
I don't understand how money works or wants to work,
you know,
when you get used to that,
just hearing that music,
you know,
being in a country that beautiful food,
that good,
everybody in their country looks like,
uh,
you know,
attractive or not everybody in Brazil seems to look like they either just got
laid and they're coming from getting laid or they're on their way to getting
laid.
It's going to the beach in Brazil.
This is amazing because you see people of every size,
every hue,
um,
you just kind of,
the beach,
the beach culture is,
it's,
it's so awesome.
And there's no,
I don't think there's any country where,
uh,
people love seem to like music and dance as,
as ferociously.
It's really tough to not dance in Brazil because everybody seems to,
wow.
So is that your favorite country?
Not there.
No,
but,
but uh,
it is,
it is one of my favorite countries.
There's something really,
really awesome about Brazil.
What's your
favorite?
I don't know.
Spain.
Spain's really awesome.
You know that Spain was where you were at that restaurant,
was it El Bulli?
Is that what you're saying?
Yeah,
but just about anywhere in Spain is this is,
this is going to be a special place with great food and it's going to be
beautiful.
Um,
Vietnam I love,
you know,
I think that Vietnam resembles all of the places I dreamed about,
and I was a little boy.
Really.
The exotic,
the exotic east,
well,
you know,
there is that,
that the decaying French aspect,
uh,
the indigenous Vietnamese,
that,
that whole part of the world looks to me particularly beautiful.
And uh,
they,
they like food in a way that,
that I find very sympathetic.
They're passionate about it.
Uh,
so Vietnam,
this dot,
that's going to be a sentimental favorite as well.
Wow.
So Vietnam?
No,
numero uno.
Huh.
Wow.
But you could do worse than you know,
to,
you know,
to Keel over after we're really good meal to eat or die with a big hunk of pork
in your mouth in Spain would not be a bad way to go out.
Anybody that doesn't appreciate the idea of cooking as an art form should watch
that show on El Bulli.
Is that,
how am I saying?
Oh boy.
Yeah.
Yay Dad.
That guy.
Wow.
What a fucking wizard.
That guy is so really intensely creative chef that had this small restaurant in
Spain as well.
I mean it was,
it was basically,
it was considered the best restaurant in the world for,
for a long time.
It's certainly he was a guy way out in front of everybody else.
Uh,
yeah,
that was some good food porn.
We did.
And I think that was a show.
And really,
you know,
every once in a while we get an opportunity to do a show that might actually
mean something in a few years.
And,
and uh,
we,
we shots,
I think we shot some history with that show because the restaurant closed the
same night.
I think that we aired the show or,
or close to it.
And uh,
you know,
that is,
that was,
that's a true artist and uh,
it was a limited period of time and that era is over and we managed to get it
on,
on tape.
So that's something I'm really proud of it.
I was confused as to what he was doing afterwards.
He was talking about you.
So he's going to start a foundation pulled together.
It's a think tank.
Essentially.
He's a creative space where people from all over the world can talk to each
other or meet,
come up with new ideas.
Yeah.
Hmm.
Trippy.
Very trippy.
Because,
you know,
I,
I have to be honest,
until I watched your show,
I never thought of food as an art form.
I always thought of food as a,
you know,
well,
there,
I think your instincts are right.
Uh,
I think there are maybe two or three people in the world who I would say,
you know,
who are shifts maybe two or three chefs in the world who you could honestly say
they're artists as opposed to really talented craftsmen.
I mean,
artists,
you know,
somebody who's creating something completely different than anybody else.
It doesn't have to absolutely be completely different because it's almost just
doing it really well and with attention to detail and like that.
That is art.
It does come through when you have a,
a big,
there's a difference between the people who designed the great cathedrals of
Europe and the people who built them.
People have built them or some of the,
probably the,
some of the greatest craftsman,
you know,
in the history of the world.
Uh,
but they were just doctor,
we're working within an established hierarchy.
They
were about doing the same thing again and again and again.
Exactly the same.
Um,
I just don't think there are that many people who,
if the bent for me,
the benchmark has Ferran Adria at Elbulli and this was a guy who was like
Charlie Parker or Jimi Hendrix.
You know,
nobody had ever made sounds out of a guitar before.
Like Jimi Hendrix,
you know,
no one had ever made sounds out of a horn.
Like Charlie Parker were unique to history.
There aren't a lot of people who will ever be that good or that different.
Um,
Ferran Adria is,
is like those guys that's so that's the high watermark for you.
So there's only a few guys like that that just really are paving a path and
doing their own.
What do we,
what do we do now?
Closed his restaurant was,
it was true traumatizing for,
I think for a lot of pieces.
He looked at the Michael Jordan of chefs sees the peak of the hill.
Right?
He's the Bruce Lee of chefs,
the Bruce Lee and Michael Jordan together.
Wow.
Yeah.
With a little bit of Dalai Lama.
Who else has left?
How many guys are left true artists?
I don't know.
I wouldn't even like to think about it.
I know there's somebody out.
This is a small handfuls that I've probably,
you know,
it's probably someone who's food I've eaten and I had just stumped too stupid to
have recognized that it was historic and great.
Well,
even the craftsman,
even if you just recreate and classic dishes,
I don't give a fuck when someone's really good at it.
It comes through as an art.
I see what you're saying.
And they might not be the innovators,
they might not be at the head of the,
you know,
there,
there are a lot of really great innovative chefs out there,
but art,
you know,
and I said,
I'll see you Saturday,
you know,
high standard for the Costco here,
right?
Yeah.
Well I'm a fucking comedian when we call comedy art,
you know,
some people would call this the art of podcasting.
It gets ridiculous.
I will,
I will go to my grave without having created any art.
I'm pretty damn sure.
Oh Wow.
You think that that's funny cause I think your book is all right man.
I don't think that's hard.
You start,
if you start talking about yourself like that,
you know,
then you start talking about yourself in the third person and after that there's
really often nothing left to do.
But you get arrested.
Like,
you know,
having beaten the transsexual hooker to death,
it's beautiful that you think like that.
That's why you're you man.
It's a beautiful way to think that is the road to madness.
And,
and,
uh,
incarceration can,
talking about yourself as an artist stepping back and you know,
as an artist,
I feel as an artist,
you know,
ever since I've been writing books as an artist,
yeah.
That's,
it's,
I don't really see,
I don't see what I do.
Anything that I do is essentially that much different than standing on a,
on a,
on a line and one of one chef or cook among many,
you know,
making food.
You know,
you're presumably your building something or making something as best you can.
You're showing up at work on time,
doing the best job you can and you're,
hopefully you're having fun doing it.
Um,
you know,
and so,
so there aren't that different.
I don't see one.
It started telling stories on television or talking about yourself,
a television.
I see it as being essentially any different,
certainly no better than,
you know,
I'm actually working for a living.
Right.
I see what you're saying.
That you are one of those guys that you know,
you could just be,
anyone could know you as that guy that you work with or the grace personalities.
Funny likes to talk shit about things.
Kind of an interesting guy.
You know,
he could be a TV star,
somebody just put a camera on them,
please.
Guy Needs his own reality show,
you know?
I mean,
how many,
how many people do you know like that?
I've,
I've known thousands of mine.
My friend Johnny being I used to,
my best friend was a professional pool hustlers,
halfway homeless.
I was sleeping on my couch on people's couches and he's a genius.
He could throw math problems out of him.
He would recreate them.
The guy like that would make a great reality show.
I think the,
if,
if television has taught us anything,
it's that,
you know,
complete mediocrity is enough to have,
uh,
you know,
you're on a reality show and you know,
it's,
it's all about your willingness to play ball.
You know,
you look at this kid's on Jersey shore,
you know,
does this situation like drive a Bentley to work,
and then he's got to sleep on a cot with a bunch of other boneheads who he
hates,
you know,
you know what I mean?
Is that really how the show works?
They all hang out together
during shooting season.
The rest,
you know,
I mean,
no,
the rest of it,
he's not taking a moped home at this point.
The way I look at him as like good for him,
you know,
what else would they be doing?
I see this as a,
as a,
as a Greek tragedy actually.
You know,
it really,
I mean,
you know,
the,
the whole dynamic has showed that they're trying hard.
They,
they,
they buy now they know that they know the charitable rules of television.
You know,
it's not about looking good.
They got that early on,
you know,
but now it's just,
they know how to play ball.
I got a good thing and they got a good gig and,
uh,
and,
and they're milking it for as long as they can,
but look at the real housewives chain,
you know,
it's like,
does anyone go on the real housewives thinking that they're going to look good?
It's not what the show's about.
It's about making people sitting on couches with,
uh,
you know,
bag of chips saying,
man,
those people are even way more fucked up than me.
And what have they done to their faces?
I mean,
who buys that?
Look up those lips.
Why Cumin has lifts like that.
And that's the chicken.
Her husband just committed suicide.
And then as business partner committed suicide too.
So everyone's saying it's all about showing up for work every day,
knowing that your job is to,
you know,
I need everyone.
Watches will feel better about themselves,
you know,
and be snickering at me.
And it was mad.
My cartoonish behavior is fascinating that the trend of reality television took
off.
But this idea of just following housewives are following guys driving on
slippery roads.
Yeah.
Ice Road truckers is a show about driving on a slippery road.
How silly is that?
You know,
there's auction shows and all these,
you know,
I don't know if it's the worst thing that ever happened in history or the,
or the best.
You know,
I,
it's weird,
you know,
I don't think it's worst or the best,
but it's definitely weird.
Like,
so,
I mean,
I do watch some of those shows.
Like Jersey shore,
I can watch only about 10 minutes of it before it just by Bible starts to
explode.
You know,
it's just too much.
It's just too,
too horrifying and yet fascinating,
you know?
So I'm good for 10 minutes of figure.
This is the greatest show that ever existed a after,
which I just,
I can't,
it's too painful.
I mean,
while that's pretty watered down,
you know,
as far as like the,
the,
the low level behavior of this country.
Have you seen the wild and wonderful whites of West Virginia now,
Johnny Knoxville documentary?
He got to see it.
It's awesome.
So few of these shows have really any,
any relationship to reality at all.
I've created this alternate reality where we'll people are behaving like,
you know,
soap,
the soap opera freaks that they're expected to behave like,
and,
and so your complicity in this whole terrible process of,
you know,
public self humiliation.
Uh,
that's kind of fascinating.
Well,
not only that,
that they also have to,
they do these fake tasks like things happen.
Oh No,
we got to get down to DMV.
I'm going to lose my license.
Sure you are.
What the fuck are you talking about?
Like this is like,
they orchestrate fake drama on fake things about,
I'm waiting for the day,
you know that,
you know,
I get the phone call from an agency and you know,
we really think celebrity rehab is a good career move right now.
You know that says something about it.
What point does this scene strategically like a good career move?
You know,
Celebrity Rehab?
Yeah,
you gotta be pretty fucked up.
Especially if you're Eric Roberts and you're just,
it's just weed that would,
that guy was the weirdest one because he got on celebrity rehab cause he said he
was having a problem with weed and then everybody else has shaken like a leaf
thrown up and says he's having coffee,
reading the papers and say this is nothing wrong with them.
You don't need to be here man.
Yeah,
but he knows the drill though.
He's got to have at least one freak out during the season.
Right?
Is that what it is?
Don't.
Those are generally the rules of,
you know,
get a bonus.
You're,
you're,
he's just thinking Cha Ching,
Cha Ching,
wells Fargo.
That's one of the most disturbing shows.
Celebrity Rehab.
Very,
very,
very disturbing.
Hard to watch.
Wouldn't you be depressed though?
Like if your agent calls you up and said,
listen,
Joe got a great offer,
celebrity rehab,
you're like,
wow,
what does it say about me?
I would,
I would like go in the bathroom and stare in the mirror for really long time
saying,
what have I done?
What have I done?
That's why it's good to have friends back home where you're like freaking out
too much.
Oh my God,
I'm drinking too much.
But you do,
uh,
week we've got wasted last night.
Blacked out Friday,
Saturday,
Sunday.
Oh God.
Right.
In their mind,
I'm fine.
Art Market Research has shown us that,
you know,
audiences really want more footage of you vomiting.
Yeah.
Well,
speaking of vomiting,
man,
do you,
you had that one episode where you took Iowasca yeah,
it was,
it was that legit.
Yeah.
I didn't,
you know,
I've taken a lot of LSD or early on in my life,
so by the time I took Iowasca for the first time,
um,
so I was like kind of,
it was,
for me,
it was kind of like ecstasy in the sense that I'm sitting around waiting to get
off.
It didn't work.
It did,
but it was a big deal.
You know,
Lsd,
now that's a drug,
you know,
things like that was my,
that was my,
that was my experience.
I think you got some low level shit and sometimes they do that.
I've always heard that from the Iowa scarecrows that they watered down the stuff
they give to the gringos.
They don't want anybody going crazy running through the woods,
seeing dragons flying fucking serpents and Ufo shows and shit.
But everybody that I know that's taken it,
it's taken legit doses,
has had crazy psychedelic Vishy.
I mean,
I went in to the experience,
you know,
it's just cottage cottage.
It's a shack up on stilts as I recall,
out in the middle of the jungle and Amazon were like four hours,
six hours by boat from any place
like resembling a place with a hospital.
Um,
no lights.
so I went into the experience with the expectation that it would be like the
book,
why would be crawling around naked in the jungle,
you know,
shitting and puking for six hours before I discovered my spirit animal.
So this is what I thought it was going into.
Um,
honestly,
I mean,
you know,
I got off the seriously.
Uh,
but,
but it wasn't like acid [inaudible] a week dose.
Yeah.
I mean I gather,
you know,
I didn't shit myself,
so it was win,
win.
Know
how deep are you in the ass and like many heads or were you a one or two or did
you like w because I used to hang out with guys would be like,
I took 11 hits and I'm like,
no,
I was done with these guys.
You'd sit around like,
you know,
take it too much.
I mean,
they know when it's enough,
right?
You make your mushrooms in a result into Arizona first or do you do anything
fancy?
Oh,
back in the day we did a marinade.
The mushrooms in honey,
I think we met already did them at honey overnight
or longer and then wouldn't mix it in what big pot of hot tea and the whole
kitchen would be
drinking this tea
and honey.
That's how I make it a tea.
That's my new thing.
I'm not suggesting you do that.
We did it.
That's what they use to use to preserve
mushrooms back in the daddy.
Yeah.
They used to preserve them and honey,
they would a dry mop and preserving them in honey and they believe that that's
one of,
that's one of the ways that people started getting into alcohol because honey
can ferment and become mead and that,
you know,
that eventually like this is like one,
a Terence Mckenna's theories that people went from being an intoxicant oriented
like with psychedelic mushrooms to alcohol oriented and that somehow another
fuck society up.
And at one time we got along way better.
He has this,
uh,
I got a great hit,
right?
History.
Actually it,
I was,
I was reading about coffee lately.
You know,
that when they first the first coffee houses in England,
uh,
we're quickly declared illegal by the,
by the government.
They saw these as hotbeds of sedition and they closed them down.
Why?
Because up until that point in history,
most Europeans and most people in England would wake up in the morning and drink
mead.
That's all they drank all day long.
It was basically,
you know,
crude beer,
homemade beer.
Um,
so up until this point in history,
when people started drinking coffee in these coffee houses,
everybody in Europe could be counted on to be fucked up all day long.
So nobody's said coffee houses with the first place in Europe where people would
sit around in a state of sobriety and,
and it's 10 people tend to do that.
You know,
when you're sober,
you noticed shit.
And they were like,
Hey,
have you noticed her governments?
Like really fucking us.
So
the government was right,
of course,
because of these was the first time that people were actually drinking a
beverage and hanging out and in with their wits about them.
And that was seen as a really dangerous thing.
Food for thought.
That's fascinating.
Well,
that's exactly what's going on with marijuana in this country.
They're trying to keep that away from people.
The good,
good percentage of it is they're worried about people waking up.
They're worried about,
well,
if I was like,
you know,
if I was president and wanted to be like reelected for a visit,
if it was a really bad precedent or,
or,
or I'd want people to smoke marijuana,
uh,
you know,
basically who spoke,
who spoke weed or generally we're talking,
yeah.
Everybody in California.
Everybody.
Yeah.
But people who,
you mean back home,
every correlation between smoking and voting,
frequency of voting.
That's what I'm wondering.
Do people like,
is there a huge I flake factor?
Oh,
for sure.
You know,
it's like some comedian was talking about this,
I don't know who did it.
It was the whole,
the whole bit of,
uh,
why,
why it's ever been,
we will never be voted in as legal because all the most fervent supporters will
forget to show up.
Yeah,
right.
I don't know who said it,
but it was really funny.
Yeah,
that is true.
A good percentage.
Well,
you know,
my,
my take on the,
the,
the amount of potheads that are useless.
It's just like my take on the amount of regular people that are useless.
There's a certain percentage,
whether it's 20 or 30,
or if you're pessimistic up to 50% of people that are just fucking useless.
And it doesn't matter if you give him marijuana,
it doesn't matter if you get them drunk,
they're just,
they're just low watt brains to change the law,
you'd need 100% turnout.
That's going to be tough.
But I've had some people that I know that have,
uh,
gotten to pot like late in life and it's completely changed the way they look at
things like for the better,
you know,
it helps them only be like,
look,
you haven't,
Smith didn't start smoking weed until three years ago.
You look at me,
I got to get to get a lot of public figures out there who would probably have
benefited from early use of psychedelics.
And unquestionably,
I mean,
Steve Jobs always talks about that,
that,
you know,
one of the,
uh,
the most powerful experiences and his life was tripping on acid.
I think some would respond well.
I think John Mccain would,
would,
would be,
uh,
different in,
in more interesting person if he'd done acid at some point in his life.
Oh,
for sure.
For sure.
And it wouldn't be so scared he would have a weekend.
Now,
others I'd be worried about.
I would be very worried about giving Michele Bachmann ass some squeaky Fromme
shit right there would be worried about giving her husband acid,
oh,
Massad and Viagra and then run.
But I would like to do acid with Bill Clinton.
Did you know,
you know who Michelle Bachmann as you know what we're talking about?
And they said,
I'd be shocking the way Bill Clinton hadn't done it.
Oh No,
he must've done it yesterday.
He's still there.
Yeah.
That was all that nonsense.
He didn't inhale.
It was back in the day.
But you,
you know,
after his,
I did not have sex with that woman.
All that.
I did not inhale really lost a lot of weight.
Yeah.
I'll never forgive him for that actually.
Just,
you know,
I don't care,
everything that he was accused of feel like I'm pretty okay with.
Treat me like an idiot though.
Yeah.
I really found on forgivable,
you know,
I really found that despicable and could never really never forget I did not
have sex.
You know,
tragically Steph says,
what,
what I understand a sexual relations is what I understand the term to be
uncommon for me.
It's unforgivable.
Yeah.
It's uh,
I also wished that he had stepped up and said it's not a for your fucking
business and wish he had said this is a ridiculous private manner and you're
trying to make it a big story.
It's really amazing.
Like,
like it seems like Marty you are and the higher you are in the,
in the public eye,
the more powerful you are,
the more likely you are to behave like the stupidest person to ever be on like
law and order.
It's like 20 year old girls do not say in your previous deposition that you did
not have said yet
readily available to.
These are two.
You're arresting officers,
you know,
where he's just so they believe that some alternate reality exists.
You know what's,
uh,
what's the inquiring and got their hooks in you.
It's time to let it hang out.
You know what?
I think certain people become delusional when they hit a certain level of
notoriety like the president of the United States.
I mean,
that level must be so intoxicating and when you're already kind of crazy,
which most people who are,
who run PR to become present in the first place,
you've gotta be at least a little bit fucking crazy.
Then all of a sudden you're there and the whole world is paying attention to
every month,
man.
You just feel like you could just stick your dick in someone's mouth.
It's like,
what's the big deal?
I'd be digging in there.
I was,
I was thinking my first order and then my first bit first thing in office,
you know,
on the president.
It's by degree.
I would,
it would make sure that it was an in and out burger in New York City.
We would need a change.
Many chains.
I mean many outlets of in and out.
You're that much of a fan of in and out Burger.
Yeah,
I would,
uh,
how would you use the power of the government to make sure that happens?
You love them that much.
It's,
it's,
I'm,
I'm bitter that we don't have them in New York.
Really?
You ever have five guys burgers?
Yeah,
I think we do five guys.
Burgers is pretty far from good.
Do you?
I'm a sentimental guy,
but this really exotic to me.
I mean,
I know there's better burgers out there,
but,
but it's something I like about it.
You just get hooked on certain tastes.
Yeah,
I kind of liked it.
Their,
their,
their business model just goes against a sentence,
you know,
against the grain.
Yeah.
It's a good business model.
It's kind of interesting.
We always try to shoot there and they never let us shoot in there.
Uh,
we've,
we've had,
uh,
we've had difficulties.
Really.
Yeah.
But we,
we got a shot.
What about the chick filet guy?
You ever tried to shoot at his place?
He's a guy.
He's a guy that doesn't open on Sunday because that's the Lord's Day.
Dark chick fil A's are closed on Sunday.
So that was the Lord's Day.
Am I kind of voting by by what?
By eating their chicken,
you know?
Anyway,
absolutely.
Right.
Yeah.
And it doesn't really matter.
It doesn't really matter.
I don't know if they'd be just a really evil corporation,
you know?
You know that they're like,
you know,
they're,
all of their products are made by you during prison children somewhere,
right?
Yes.
That matters.
Yeah.
But the chick fil a guy who believes in the baby Jesus,
you know,
he doesn't want to work on Sunday.
Who gives a shit?
Yeah.
I think they ended upward or guys or there was a religious component to the,
to the company at some point or the underlying philosophy.
But the point is they've apparently created this look really pretty cool
business model for,
for fast food.
And it's an issue that I think about a lot because I had some,
I don't know which economists.
Somebody said,
somebody smarter than me,
you know,
another 15 years,
we're going to be a country.
Everybody in the country,
we'll all be selling cheeseburgers to each other.
That that will be what Americans do.
You know,
we don't make anything anymore really.
manufacturing is dropped to nothing.
We're,
we're into making,
you know,
transformers seven and uh,
and uh,
you know,
selling each other burgers before the economy even collapse.
Putin was quoted as saying,
I don't understand the American economy.
It seems that all they do is sell houses to each other.
It was right about that.
He's right about that.
You know,
I mean,
it's truthfully that,
what are,
what is our,
I think what our best export,
you know,
or now,
honestly,
now it's culture.
It's,
it's,
it,
it is,
is pretty close.
Second,
I think,
you know,
music for TV and comedies,
it's is a,
it is our most powerful weapon and our most powerful,
I think it's what we do best,
you know,
for better or worse.
I mean,
I agree 100% especially,
you know,
television and films.
I mean,
you know,
is it a po post other countries ever,
every now and then another country and make a good movie.
But goddamn there's a giant chunk of on the come from this fucking wacky place.
Yeah.
Do you ever go someplace where you go,
Ooh,
being from America might be kind of touchy here.
Um,
there have been places where I thought that was going to happen.
We're in fact,
we were treated really,
really,
really well.
Like where,
where'd you worry?
Well,
everywhere in Arab world,
the hospitality has been unbelievable.
Saudi Arabia,
I was apprehensive.
You know,
they,
they take a lot of Saudis take uh,
a very,
have a very different view of the world than I do for sure.
Um,
but no,
I think everywhere I've been,
uh,
again,
it's kind of about the people who've been incredibly hospitable in places that I
didn't expect a upfront they would have any particular love for Americans.
Vietnamese were incredible from the first time I went there.
Um,
you know,
a lot of bad history there.
Are you going to ask?
At one point I turned to somebody I was with,
I said,
aren't you guys pissed?
You know
what,
why don't you cranky about anything?
And they're like,
you know,
don't flatter yourself to,
life's hard out here.
You know,
don't even consider yourself special since you,
we fought the Chinese,
the Cambodia,
the Chinese again before you there was the French,
the Japanese,
uh,
the Chinese.
We've been at war for 600 years.
You know,
you were only around for x.
So they take a really professional kind of long view.
Basically.
What if we stopped fighting this week?
Next week you're welcome at my house.
We'll hang out,
we'll talk.
Shop will get fucked up.
Tell some gels.
Wow.
Generally speaking,
what I mean,
so that,
that's a place where people have been really hospitable,
that I didn't expect it.
Uh,
well,
a lot of places,
you know,
should we shut off the villas in,
in Rio and basically,
you know,
very poor,
very crime ridden areas of,
uh,
of,
Rio and,
uh,
when,
Cyrus place,
you have to sort of hook up with the local crime guy.
You know,
whoever the mayor of the block,
the Ma,
no,
no.
This is our fixer.
We'll contact you want to shoot in this area.
You're going to need somebody local godfather or the head of the crew or whoever
controls that area in the real world.
We have to contact them and say,
listen,
we're going to make a point of coming at you,
showing you respect,
offering you a few dollars because it's never about the money.
You know,
and you will get to wander around and shoot your whole area of your city without
fear of being shot or stabbed or robbed.
And um,
and we do that again and again and again.
We just show the respect of acknowledging for better or worse,
you are the boss of this neighborhood.
We're going to show you,
respect the front of your neighbors and you will keep us from Kevin shot while
we're shooting in the neighborhood.
Again,
it's just about,
it's not,
you know,
we're not paying people.
It's people are proud of their food.
Chances are that proud of their neighborhood,
they're proud of their friends.
If somebody expresses interest in telling their story or sh or showing the world
what they do,
particularly if there's food involved in local beverage,
chances are you're going to have a good time.
You're going to be treated well in this world.
One of the most kind of heartwarming,
really cool homie moments was when you were in Naples and that guy took you into
his house for Sunday dinner and a sort of a last minute thing.
It was totally minute
our,
our fixer had had hooked us up with a family.
You know,
I know a friend of a friend and that fell through at the last minute and you
know,
literally
the car of my drivers is not a good,
just come over to my mother's house.
My mother will cook for you.
Sure.
She'll be on TV.
I'll tell her tomorrow.
It was perfect.
It was made when you walk in.
I knew this woman is like made for television.
She was just so completely real and awesome and tough.
She's like chain smoking while she's cooking,
stirring the sauce.
She had this way of target,
Eh,
she's talking about her side.
Oh man,
there was,
yeah,
you couldn't,
you couldn't put that in an Adam Sandler movie.
People would think you were too over the top.
It's really great.
It's really great when you get lucky when you,
when you're shooting and something really amazing happens.
You meet and the food looked fucking Jama where that meat was boiling in that
sauce.
Oh,
oh.
It was bubbling that he knew it was on for hours.
It was just going to just melt in your mouth.
That show was one of those where it just totally did not suck.
Making that show and we all,
everybody on the crew games like five pounds.
I gained five pounds watching your fucking shows.
I eat at night when everybody's asleep.
That's when I watch your show.
I cook something and then I'll sit in front of your show and eat way more than I
should.
What I do generally is fine.
If I know I'm shooting in Rome or Naples,
anywhere in Italy or eastern Europe,
you know,
with dumpling land,
I'll make sure that the next show is in someplace really empowered land.
Right.
Or,
or,
or with a really,
like maybe Vietnam,
some places are pretty light,
uh,
cuisine.
You know,
where you found it out.
Yeah.
I,
we learned our lesson.
We,
I think we did Brittany and Provence in a row,
you know,
so the whole crew were all together for like 18 days in France of on a,
on a food show.
So,
you know,
ordering just like lots of stuff.
Everyone in the crew game,
eight,
10 pounds,
you know,
that people in France with,
they're incredibly rich.
Diets are thin.
They bought their way fitter than Americans.
They move,
they move around a lot.
Yeah.
They're always pedaling around and shit.
Walking around doing all this crazy,
cooky European shit.
Look around and shed is Drylok they're active.
They're not a sedentary society.
Uh,
that I will see them and you know,
anaphase,
it'll look how they,
the same with the Italians.
They'll eat,
they don't eat breakfast.
Really.
Maybe they'll have a tiny nibble of a muffin or requests on a couple of
shooters.
A coffee get really jacked up on coffee.
They get through,
you know,
maybe they'll take a nip nipper something maybe around one o'clock in the
afternoon.
They knock off for a couple of hours and eat a huge motherfucking meal and a lot
of wine.
Then they go back to work and they work till like seven or eight or nine
sometimes.
Then they have maybe a light supper.
You know,
generally speaking,
we're talking to average,
um,
then a very light supper.
You know,
they're not sitting down and doing it all again.
It's all about either lunch or dinner,
you know,
so they're really eating only one big meal a day.
A friend of mine went to the land on eating deep fried fuckin macaroni,
macaroni and cheese,
or,
you know,
cheeseburgers between the doughnuts or they don't do that.
A buddy of mine went to the Lamborghini factory.
He,
uh,
you know,
my friend Bud who owns that show rides.
They filmed the construction of a Lamborghini and he came back.
The first thing he said is,
does fucking people know how to live?
He goes,
let me tell you something.
First of all,
they go to work about 10,
10,
30.
No one's there at like 7:00 AM they get in,
they were for a little bit.
Then they eat a spectacular lunch.
Well they have chefs come in and make them the most incredible pasta and then
they sleep for a couple of hours and they come back in and they work for a
couple more hours and then they're done.
No one's working like 12 hours days at the Lamborghini factory.
They're just artists making these incredible here.
Why can't we,
is it possible to sustain 300 million people and have that sort of a work ethic
goes God,
Dan has to be a way better place,
you know,
for a regular job.
I mean if you're working on your own shit,
you should be able to do whatever you want.
I expect something I ask all the time,
you know,
my wife says,
and,
and I spent a lot of time there and I look around at,
you know,
guys in their twenties and thirties and how do,
how do you live?
But constantly asking myself,
how do you live this way?
Who's giving you money?
Nobody seems to really,
people do work hard in Italy,
but you just tend to not see it.
Um,
beat motherfucking lunch every day and I mean,
we'd be a little gelato at four o'clock in the afternoon.
You getting your weeks of vacation a year,
you don't win in France and in Italy too,
you know,
you get sick in the middle of the night,
you pick up a phone call,
a doctorate in like 15 minutes later.
So some young intern arrives on a,
on a,
on a motor scooter,
shoots you up with whatever drugs you need to feel better at your house.
It's like,
like free or close to free.
They don't even take tips.
It's fucking nuts.
Wow.
They come to your house,
they will come to your house,
all doctor bag and can you imagine this?
You know,
and they come quit.
That's what happens when you have a small culture.
When you have a culture of too many millions of people,
you have the diffusion of responsibility thing.
You'd,
the numbers are too big and there's no way he could rock that.
I don't have a rock.
I don't know.
Listen,
I still the,
I don't know how they do it,
but they do.
Their priorities are very,
very different.
But I'll tell you a quality of life does not suck.
Does not suck.
And how many people live there total?
I Dunno.
It's not that many.
Right?
I don't know.
Uh,
Oh,
you're asking me population of France or Italy?
Is it like a couple million each?
What does it have?
No idea.
It's not like a major American city.
Right?
I just think this rock countries in Europe with fewer people than,
than New York City,
that's for sure.
For sure.
I mean,
New York City's the most amazing city on the planet,
but I just think that anytime you jammed that many people in one spot,
you're asking for,
you're asking for some unnatural reactions.
You know,
I dunno.
I'm,
I'm fascinated by how well New York works.
It's incredibly efficient.
I mean by and large,
just watching taxis.
Like one of the things I love doing in New York is driving,
everyone else hates to drive to New York.
I love driving in New York.
I love how traffic these cars should be smacking up against each other,
particularly the way the taxis drive and they're bombing up,
you know,
bombing up an avenue,
looking to hit the lights,
changing lanes without even touching the directionals.
There's something,
um,
mystically
cooperative about the way it all works.
There's an ebb and flow to New York City traffic that when you get up,
it's in,
you know,
into that wave.
It's like birds and the dusk skies and those big waves.
When birds flying those big waves,
they don't hit each other.
Coming from an ag downtown,
when you hit every light that's,
I've been hit by a cab,
so I used to drive a New York cab,
sent me twice and they bolted both times.
Those Fox I've been hit by,
I've been hit by cab.
I'd be in a cab and been t boned twice.
Oh,
in in like three days.
God Damn.
Twice in three days.
You're having never been involved in anything like that?
A few years back.
Wow.
Was it both on the same side or do double size in it yet?
I just got out,
jumped into one of the cab,
you know,
he's one of those things.
That one was her shit.
So it was a light t bone.
Well it was a,
we,
nobody was driving away,
you know,
she wasn't actually one guy did drive away but you don't want to rims with spa.
It was a stolen car and there were clearly it appeared to be a stolen car cause
the guy got out of there awful quick on,
on rims.
Uh,
New York City is just such a fascinating experiment to stack people on top of
each other all in this one place and have all you know,
pretty much anything you need right there.
Do you own a restaurant?
No.
No,
no.
I was a chef at a restaurant for many years.
I'm still involved with them and uh,
I dunno it when is the last time you were in the weeds chalk?
11 years.
11 years,
yeah.
It's been a,
let me see here.
The weeds.
Did you just give him shop talk?
Yes,
it's been 11 years since I've been on the line regularly since,
since I've had a show up.
And actually work a station every day.
Yeah.
It was a fun show.
When you did go back to your,
your,
your New York City restaurant,
how do you see that lay out and yeah,
what are you going to get time you come to a terms from very quickly with your
own mortality and a leader?
Limitations.
Uh,
you know,
I tried to work by all double shift.
I did work my old double shifts,
um,
and I made it but you know,
I think it was 54 53 when I went back and did that shelf and uh,
I'd been away for almost 10 years.
Um,
it is like a riding a bicycle and that you,
you could still do it,
but your brain,
when you were a chef,
I think your brain starts to turn to mush in your late thirties.
You become less smart,
less fast,
less able to do,
you know,
12,
13 things at the same time because that way it starts to fry.
That is a big part of what being a chef is not just about the artistry of
preparing the food,
but of juggling all these different,
mostly to demean them.
80% of it.
I've even the great artists,
the great chefs,
um,
they're great chefs because they're able to choose people,
make personal and professional relationships with those people such that they
can execute their vision,
their artistic vision again and again and again.
Exactly the same every single day.
Rain or shine and working in high tension close quarter's everybody's and you're
talking about a liter,
a chef.
The chef is,
is a,
is a cook who leads and,
and uh,
a great chef is one who is both a,
someone who's really creative and has a,
for lack of a better word,
artistic style or vision or something to say,
but the ability to inspire a loyalty and good performance in others,
uh,
is key.
Absolutely.
You know,
could be the best,
best cook in the world.
If you can inspire others to execute that,
you ain't worth shit.
I never got this from any other show before.
I watch your show before I watch your show.
I got,
oh,
that guy cooks good food.
I really did.
I mean,
I just,
I don't Kmart minimalized.
I don't,
I don't have enough room in my brain for everything.
You know,
I can't focus on everything.
So I'd see certain things and I learn as little as I need to know.
Oh,
I like this kind of food.
that tastes good.
Oh,
that guy's a good cook.
Awesome.
Eating his food.
I never thought about it in terms of the complexity or the,
the effort that goes into it.
And I really never thought about it that much until your show.
That's why it was so fascinating to me.
It's hard.
It's hard on you
glamorous work,
you know.
So by the time the shaft becomes the chef that,
you know,
by the time you know their name,
chances are they're not working the line anymore,
but that they spent most of their adult lives,
uh,
standing there doing something that is very similar in many ways to work in a
production line,
in a,
in an auto factory.
You know,
you putting the nuts of the balls in the same places,
presumably every time and just as well.
And then one guy pops out like a Wolfgang Puck or,
uh,
the,
the Emeril dude that his own fucking Sitcom.
Well,
they,
you know,
guys like Emerald didn't pop out actually.
I mean,
that's a guy who worked his ass off for a really long time,
uh,
in restaurants,
became well known,
was offered a show,
was a particularly good at,
and he had one show after another fail in the network,
stuck with him,
and he's moved.
More importantly,
he's stuck with it.
And He created a very,
he became a very improbable,
you know,
superstar.
Uh,
you know,
if you look at those early shows,
it's just,
you know,
he does everything.
So many things wrong as far as what you expect of a classic,
you know,
TV friendly guy.
You know,
he's got a thick accent.
He's kind of a little awkward up there.
That was really charming and he really,
audiences like that.
But,
but you know,
he worked his ass off getting there.
He didn't just say he wasn't like me an overnight success guy.
You know,
he,
he was drilling away for years.
But what I'm,
what I meant by it is it all of a sudden he's forced into the public
consciousness that he's launched.
Like emeralds.
I,
there's a,
there's a few guys is like the Wolfgang Puck's.
There's,
if you're not paying attention,
these are the guys that you hear about if you're not paying attention.
Well,
cause they're,
you know,
they're both guys who've been around a long time and done really important
things both off TV and on TV.
Um,
it's interesting that he's,
they'd love him for his personality.
So like your personality is so good.
We're going to ask you to fake it now.
It has to be in a sitcom
for all,
for a long time.
You know,
chefs,
a lot of chefs got into the business because they were awkward.
They felt awkward,
they were shit.
Words are generally didn't feel comfortable in a straight business environment.
Uh,
the chancellor of the kind of running away from something,
they sent something about themselves that,
that,
that said,
all,
all of the things that tell you subconsciously bad communicator,
you know,
shouldn't be out there talking to regular people on a regular basis trying to do
normal business.
Those are the things that drove people to cook.
And yet suddenly they find themselves,
you know,
with media coaches and people trying to train them to be themselves on camera.
And it's a huge industry.
And,
and uh,
a strange,
strange one.
Yeah.
You,
I,
I read a quote once where he said that,
uh,
the,
the guys that got into becoming chefs where the second smartest sons,
well,
traditionally in European culture,
you know,
if the family could only afford to send one kid to college,
they pick the smartest son.
And they invest what little money they had and that enterprise,
the other one would join the family business or go go to hotel school to be,
to learn.
You'd literally to be an apprentice to some craft,
you know,
some trade.
And for a lot of people that was hotel school.
So all a lot of the great chess that came out of that,
that kind of situation.
Certainly when I started cooking,
it was the,
the misfits who ended up in the restaurant business,
you know,
life hacking exactly.
Turned out the way they had expected.
Or maybe there's a,
a quick,
you know,
a temporary,
you could,
you know,
there's always a job for you if,
if,
if you,
you're presented a reasonably intelligent,
there's always a job for you on the floor of a restaurant as a waiter.
And I'm in that though,
right?
You take joy in being one of the misfits.
Oh,
let me just,
why I got an a business.
It was running away with the circus.
It was fellow misfits and refugees who,
who really just couldn't hack it anywhere else ended up in this,
this enterprise.
Um,
see,
that was the first time I'd ever seen it or heard it described like that.
It was listening to you talk about it.
I had never thought of working in a kitchen to be like that.
Yeah,
well it was a lot of fun.
I mean it was a,
it was a lot of fun.
I think
how many people have worked in restaurants at one point or another in life?
It is an education.
It's one of the things I love one of the,
there's so many things to love about it that special about it.
You see people again and again.
I used to see these guys that come out of like the mountains of Afghanistan,
like,
or the tribal areas of Pakistan,
you know,
really,
um,
you know,
conservative background.
Uh,
never been any city until they came to New York.
They're working in a restaurant as busboys four weeks later.
It's not motherfucker [inaudible] son of a bitch,
you know,
rat best.
And then they basically,
you've immediately adopted sort of the,
the worst of New York culture is a,
a speech,
but they're also,
you get so smart about,
about human behavior.
When you're a or a waiter,
you see so much of it.
It's like being a bartender.
You learn way more about human nature,
then you really want to learn,
you know,
uh,
you didn't sign up to be a psychiatrist,
but in the aura,
an enabler,
a doctor.
But in the end,
that's kind of what you become when,
if you're a bartender with regulators.
So I think people in the restaurant business get this really unique view of the
world perspective on the rest of the world.
Yeah.
It is a unique position to be a bartender,
to be the sober person serving everyone drinks while they're all just falling
apart and talking to you gets to some,
it gets to some of confused why it gets to some people.
I knew a bartender who,
uh,
I'd be drinking with them.
I do my shift drink with him after I worked the lunch service and this guy was
telling me,
you don't have to 10,
12 years in the business.
I don't know if I could do this much longer now.
I just don't know if I could do it.
And I said,
why?
He says,
watch this.
He takes the big glasses and I guess he presses them in the sponge,
rinse them with,
with uh,
with kosher salt and puts them under the bar.
It's old lady comes in and sits down.
I like a salty dog,
you know,
he,
he pours his salty dog,
she drinks it,
she orders another,
he has a second glass for,
uh,
she drinks it.
Then she gets into this,
okay.
That,
that's enough for me.
Gets up,
makes it halfway to the door,
looks at the ground.
Second thoughts goes back to the bar orders of third point is he'd had the three
glasses ready.
He knew this is a,
this one is an alcoholic.
Okay.
I am helping her on her way to her ultimate destruction.
And I just,
I can't hack it,
you know,
but I have too many customers like this,
you know?
Well,
ultimately if you're in the bar every night,
you know,
and bars are great once a week bars,
a great once a month if you can,
you know,
once a month,
if you stay healthy and you're feeling good,
your immune system's up.
You've been eating vitamins and eating well,
you just get fucked up with still had,
c'mon,
everything's good.
But you're doing that every night.
I would,
you know,
it will cure you of the nightclubs real fast.
This working in a nightclub and I worked at a nightclub and that was,
I will never,
you know,
never again.
You know any place where it's like the background.
I'm already out the other door.
Yeah,
yeah,
I did.
Uh,
some,
uh,
security work at a concert center in Massachusetts.
Great Woods.
You've got to see people at like Neil young concerts.
People fucked up in the crowd that I would never want to be a part of anything
like that ever.
I knew that I had like 19.
I'm like,
I gotta get the Fuck Outta here.
Cause place I worked with,
they were sued like two,
three times a week,
you know,
which you,
I guess you,
you are when you're in the nightclub business because there's always some
boneheads who come in,
you know,
pick a fight,
uh,
bounces,
throw them out already.
There's a lawsuit.
It doesn't mean it's a credible one,
but people are going to be suing you,
your,
uh,
your competition are going to be suing you.
Uh,
the fire department is going to be harassed.
It's,
I've just brutal,
it's amazing that people can sell alcohol at all.
It's amazing.
You know,
that
people can afford to have bars begin afford to sell alcohol at all because you
would think that people getting drunk and cost so many fucking problems and they
can be sued for just,
it was,
it was an education,
I think it was two years at this very busy New York nightclub and just the stuff
that people would leave in the,
in the,
in the bathrooms are try to flush down the toilet.
We have the night cleanup guy would always come by the kitchen with his
discoveries of the night.
You know,
it was a fucking artificial limb.
Oh my God.
It was,
the women's rooms were actually always worse,
way worse.
You know,
people were like just doing,
I mean,
it's just incredible,
you know,
horrifying.
You know,
museum tells a story of human behavior that you just don't want to know it's
fucking alcohol man,
and wind him up and set them loose.
I had a buddy who was a,
did his residency in Miami and he said on Friday and Saturday nights,
people would come in with light bulbs up their assets.
It's just impossible things,
you know,
just mostly shoved up their asses,
bullet holes,
people just getting just Barb and off.
It really truly is amazing that you can sell alcohol and you can't sell weed
weed.
So what a,
what a beautiful thing they've done.
It makes no sense at all.
Unless we make it,
we grow such good wheat in this country.
It would be a huge,
a major export.
I mean,
who does,
who grows better weed and us?
Nobody.
There's no better botanist in the southern California assholes.
These guys assholes and I saying with all love,
what they've done done now is incredible.
Look at this shit.
This is a marijuana electric cigarette.
Perfect for plane,
bathroom.
You get smoke this on a plane.
Wow.
It's one of those electronic cigarettes and has gotten,
we'd there,
they're fucking scientists.
Wow.
They're taking it to the next slot.
But science is great but it's amazing.
But unfortunately they're still getting arrested for it.
There's still people that are getting,
apparently Obama said that he was only going to go after people who violate both
federal and state law,
but I don't know if that's been,
I think it's probably pretty easy to violate state law too.
Yeah.
I mean I think we should,
we should,
if we're going to do it,
if we're going to allow people to smoke weed that we should be making money off
it as it as an issue.
Yeah.
Selling serious wait to like Europe and,
and uh,
do you ever go to Mexico?
Uh,
yeah.
I love Mexico.
Do you ever go to like border towns?
I've been meaning like what do you,
what do you like to sit and just did a show?
We just did a show there.
Yeah.
I mean it's crazy.
You know what we would consider apocalyptic violence.
I mean,
I think where people have been killed in Mexico during the drug wars,
then,
you know,
I think both Gulf wars and Afghanistan,
I mean,
there's some spectacular number of people as far as water down there in,
in the American troops.
Huge numbers.
Um,
what,
you know,
I have not a clue what to do.
Uh,
you know,
it doesn't help that we're selling them guns.
Uh,
but,
but there is no doubt that,
that,
uh,
people that they would get them from somewhere.
Um,
I've never had,
I've never seen it the many times I've been in Mexico.
You know.
What's your favorite place in Mexico?
Oh,
I love Pueblo.
I love you.
You've never seen a drug violence at all.
I have not seen up close,
uh,
drug violence.
I have been in really drug,
I'd been in like super druggy neighborhoods in favelas,
in Brazil and elsewhere.
But I was with the local dealer because that's what I'm saying.
I mean,
does that work in Mexico?
Could you do something which should be safely go to a cocktail of cartel
neighborhood with a cartel guy?
Man,
the level of violence is so spectacular there.
I wouldn't want to be complicit.
You know what I mean?
If you're,
you're currently,
you know Jonathan People's heads off by the,
by the dozens,
you know,
it's another,
it's one thing.
Have you ever been around someone like that in another country in it?
For many people I have met people and done scenes of my show with people who
have done very,
very bad things in their lives.
No question about it.
Um,
they were not currently at the time of the show other than,
you know,
there was some low level guys for sure who clearly were drug dealers.
They said as much,
they said,
could you please shoot just this side of the street cause this side is my drug
operation.
Will you make you make a,
you make concessions,
compromises,
you know,
morally and,
and otherwise when you take advantage of a situation like that,
the only way you're gonna shoot the neighborhood is that to have a local drug
dealer holding your hand.
That's what you do.
Or where you choose not to.
Depending.
And in Mexico,
the level of violence is so spectacular.
And they see presumably the major dealers out there are killing large numbers of
people in on a regular and ongoing basis.
I would feel bad.
That's not an arrangement.
I'd end arena.
And would you have to go into some sort of a sense,
a similar arrangement if you were ever to go to the Congo?
What'd you have to [inaudible]?
Good,
good question.
But who,
who's the rebel?
And also there's,
there's uh,
it's,
uh,
what does that even there are a lot of them saying the rebels were there a lot
of,
well,
there are,
there are various malicious,
yeah,
for sure.
Yeah.
You got to ask yourself that all the time.
But in,
in the same way when really when people are trying to be really nice to you in
countries where you're not free to speak your mind,
Cuba would be an example.
Uh,
you know,
China,
uh,
up near the Tibetan border,
you know,
when you have to,
you have to understand when you're talking to people on camera who let you into
their homes and they fed you and they've got,
you know,
they've,
and they've been maybe
a little more frank with you on a personal level than,
than they are probably supposed to as government functionaries.
Um,
when they're good to you and everything they said was going to happen,
happen the way it was supposed to and they,
they didn't,
they weren't too clumsy and they didn't try to hand fist you basically,
if we get to go back to New York,
they have to stay there.
So if I go back and start criticizing as severely as I might,
it's something I always have to weigh.
The people who were good to me in these countries,
they're going to be at a very bad place.
If I go back to New York and make this really make the show all about China,
Tibet,
I may have my opinions on it,
but for the sake of the people I leave behind,
I'm not shooting my mouth off.
I could say what I want about China anytime I want and you have,
I suffer no consequences.
Anyone who was ever nice to us,
we'll be suspect.
If I were to start really going off on a tangent on the issue,
on the show that these people helped me make,
same in Cuba.
You,
you do make certain compromises because people are as straight with you as they
can be.
Um,
they do the best by you.
They're people who are nice and the senses of humor is trying to do the best
they can,
whether you agree with their system or,
or despise it.
Um,
at the end of the day,
you got to ask yourself,
do I really want to put,
you know,
it might make more entertaining or truthful television,
but they're going to be in a fucking cell for the crime of being nice to me are
being honest with me.
That's something we gotta ask ourselves all the time.
Well,
I know you couldn't put that in the shell like this show on Cuba,
but is there anything that you could,
is there anything you can talk about?
Well,
I could have gone on and on and on about,
you know,
the history of the regime and what they've done.
Right,
right.
Many of them,
incredibly unpleasant to say the least.
Um,
I didn't make the show about that.
I kept at a very,
I tried very hard to keep the focus on does it look pretty,
is it worth looking at?
Is the food good?
Are The people nice?
Wow.
They were,
um,
really tried to avoid any politics at all.
But what was amazing,
what's political is always political when you sit down eat because the fact that
they're not eating much beyond rice and beans,
that is already a political statement,
you know,
that says a lot more about a culture then they may want you to see it's
dangerous information,
but,
but there it is.
So were they allowed to complain about that at all?
Do they cautious about doing that?
Did.
They made sure that they didn't say anything.
They go,
they let us,
they let us shoot pretty much anything.
Anything we asked to shoot,
they let us shoot.
I,
I think they trust,
they clearly trusted us.
They saw us show other parts of the world in a relatively nonjudgmental way and,
and the foolishly,
or not
shrewdly or foolishly,
there will be differences of opinion.
I'm sure for whatever reason they trusted us to come and they pretty much let us
wander around shooting what kind of claims they tried.
Of course they,
you know,
there was definitely
concern over who we'd be talking to and what they might say.
Uh,
but you know,
you know,
everybody has to be careful about what they say.
Everybody changes their behavior when they talk to you to a certain extent.
You don't bring up certain subjects because they're going to worry.
Does the government have any say?
Do they,
do they pull you aside and they say,
what is it?
How are you going to show range all of this through,
through the government.
I mean,
nothing happens.
You don't go wandering around Cuba with a television crew without the government
become involved,
whether you know it or not,
but like did you get involved in any of the questions that they asked about the
cause you're,
you obviously have a creative influence.
They don't.
We're not making any show ever where they,
the nation or the local police or any other person has final cut or approval
over what we're showing now.
You obviously have approval over what we're allowed to shoot,
but how we edit that back in New York and what we say,
you know,
you're on your own.
It's too late.
Done.
You've signed a release that I ever,
ever,
ever going to happen.
Did they express any concern about any of that?
It seems like you mean they weren't very techy.
They were very,
I think their very being very shrewd about tourism.
They understand what it is that people want to see in Cuba,
which is the old Cuba of,
of a godfather to,
that's what we want to see and it's still there and have been really smart about
not fucking that up.
So these aren't as stupid,
unsophisticated people.
You're a commie functionaries.
Okay.
There they understand that they have a problem.
They,
if they,
I think everybody understands that the regime is,
you know,
things are going to change.
I think people,
everybody is kind of holding their breath in the country waiting to see what
happens next.
And I think what happens next and it's like completely in blindingly obvious to
everyone.
I mean,
Castro dies,
they open everything up pretty,
pretty damn quick.
Yeah.
And then everything gets better.
Way Better for the Cuban people sorta,
sorta if we can.
Yes.
I assume,
you know,
lose certain things though.
You're going to lose those guys arguing.
You know,
it's easy for me.
I really don't want to see a brand new holiday inn on the waterfront of,
of,
uh,
the Malecon and Havana because it's one of those beautiful stretches of,
of anywhere,
anywhere.
Um,
but that's easy for me to say.
I'm not Cuban.
I didn't lose my home.
Uh,
you know,
I,
I have to say,
I had no moral problems going to Cuba,
let's put it that way.
Um,
but I've,
I've since met a lot of Miami Cubans who take a very different view of going to
Cuba.
Um,
and it has been pointed out to me.
One guy came up to me and we were shooting at his restaurant.
It was just a complete coincidence after the,
our Cuba showed air.
This guy was pissed.
Uh,
it had clearly been a big issue at his house.
Um,
he was really struggling to contain his anger and be courteous,
which he was incredibly courteous.
And when he said,
I just need you to look at this picture.
And he takes me back and she has a picture of his dad who ran a,
basically he sold fish.
So I'd always thought that,
you know,
people who lost their homes and ran off to Miami,
we're all,
you know,
the rich and the know the bastards basically,
this was what this man was telling me is that my father was an ordinary
businessman.
You know,
who'd worked hard in a selling fish,
catching fish and selling fish,
and they took his business and,
and did his livelihood.
That's something,
you know,
it was a very hard show to balance.
Let's put a taller,
I'd imagine it's gotta be so strange to just hop from one culture to the next
one unique insight into this totally different environment.
And then another one just as extremely different.
We're really hoping to shoot and Libya in January,
we'd hoped to talk to me about this at the UFC.
We want it so bad.
I mean,
ideally we would have been there when they got good coffee,
you know.
Um,
but I,
I have friends there who've been in and out,
uh,
people we've worked with,
some of the,
some of the dicier places.
We worked with,
some very interesting security guys.
And,
uh,
some of them have been working in Libya lately and we were getting sort of
dispatches of what life's like there.
And these guys were,
these are hardened professionals who've been around.
They've been in a lot of wars,
they've seen a lot of conflicts.
Um,
in many ways you would,
you,
you would probably call the mercenaries in an earlier day.
Uh,
but they were really sentimental about Libya.
They were like,
dude,
it's awesome.
What's happening here?
You should come.
You know,
it's like all these young people from all over the world,
you know,
of Libyan back or they'll come in here and like welding machine guns on their,
on their pickup trucks and there's this really magical thing.
You know,
I'm actually thinking of pitching in.
Well apparently,
you know,
it's nice to see the bad guys actually Lucas,
right?
It is.
If it's that clear,
you know?
Yeah.
I mean that's,
I think that's exactly what I'm getting at where not a lot of people would look
at Gadhafi and say,
well that's that.
I would be unhappy to see his head being kicked across the public square.
I wouldn't be at happy seeing that.
You know what,
I don't think.
Yeah.
Get,
get off.
He is about as big a piece of shit in the world of,
you know,
rulers as you can get.
He's a,
he's a nice villain.
He wears a good black hat.
It's,
it's a,
it's a feel good for everybody and they're doing it.
The basically that,
I mean there,
there's NATO support,
but they're basically doing it for himself.
And that guy,
General Wesley Clark,
remember that guy ran for president a while back.
He predicted all of this in 2007 on one miles CNN or one of those fucking shows
or he got on and he talked about the,
the United States,
his agenda as far as acquiring,
you know,
um,
natural resources all over the world.
And Libya was right in the pile.
Libya,
Iraq,
Afghanistan,
Pakistan.
It was all these different countries where any describe it all in 2007 and
slowly but surely all these things again and implemented.
I think it,
I think what we're seeing in Egypt and Libya and Syria and Tunisia,
I think actually what we're seeing is something we didn't pretend.
It didn't predict we,
we didn't make it happen.
It's happening.
It's in many ways frightening to us.
I mean,
I,
I think the fact that all these governments are topic is not necessarily good
for our American business interests.
I happen to think it's a really good thing.
I'm happy to see it.
Like I don't really care what kind of site guys take over Egypt.
Just the fact that,
you know,
even a bad guys ended up running Egypt again.
The fact that they could,
it was possible to get and they get topple those particular bad bastards who'd
been around forever.
It was unthinkable a year ago to your average Egyptian that their government,
that things would ever change ever in their lifetime or their children's
lifetime.
And it was an unthinkable at these dynasties would ever fall.
So it's really kind of awesome.
Just the fact that it sends a message that it can happen.
You know,
I think as good one,
I don't think it falls into the,
you know,
when I'm waiting for that big payday from a rock that was opposed to,
how are we supposed to be pumping the oil straight into American coffers?
Right.
But now that ain't gonna happen.
I think a,
it depends on who you're paying attention to or who you want to believe and it
comes to that world.
But you know,
there's a lot of people that believe that we've hit some sort of a peak oil
stage and what they're trying to do is just control all the areas where,
which will be absolutely necessary when oil gets to the point where we're going
to have to start rationing things,
we do in a really bad job then because the Chinese are basically snapping at all
up.
It'd be every,
everywhere you go in Africa now it's like,
oh look at that nice new bridge.
We have the Chinese bought and paid for it.
Everywhere you go.
Like this is amazing.
Every major infrastructure,
a development that you see in places like Liberia,
um,
other African countries you've been to,
it's like,
oh,
there's those really thoughtful Chinese were here a,
I'm full Chinese and they bought all our oil,
at least 50% of the world's oil,
I think in like another,
maybe it's 10 years soon.
China alone will need,
when I first went to China,
it was like everybody was on bicycles and there's cars.
Second time I went it's like 50 50 now it's just cars,
cars,
cars.
As far as,
and how much time is this been?
10 years.
Wow.
It's so just accelerating in China.
It is,
you know,
what do they sound?
The Simpsons welcome future masters.
So future your overlord.
So we welcome you.
So is it,
what,
is it just the way they've,
uh,
they handle business is different in China now because they were much more
strict as far as commerce and things,
right?
They had much more rules,
communism on their necks.
No,
but I mean,
in a lot of ways it was like,
wait a minute,
you want to make China,
uh,
a competitive free market.
It's like,
are you out of your minds?
They'll kill us.
Then the really dangerous because there's a lot of them.
They work really hard.
They,
they,
they've been put the,
the,
they're willing to work to get things.
Uh,
that's already an advantage over,
you know,
uh,
we're entitled,
we feel entitled.
We've times have been good for us.
So,
you know,
I grew up of a generation where we were all,
we were taught that it automatically,
you know,
our lives would be better than our parents.
I took that as religious dictum that was straight from God,
you know.
Okay.
I was disappointed somewhat,
but I basically,
I'm lazier than most of the people I,
I was raised to be lazier and I am lazier then the great majority of people you
see in China and India.
Um,
for instance,
who,
you know,
see though,
it's no accident,
you see these people take a double majors,
you know,
um,
the parents were rice farmers,
you know,
and,
and the kids are now in university,
ferociously competitive.
Um,
you know,
that's what,
that's what it's about.
The desire for a,
for a different life.
We,
we got that life already.
So it's gonna be hard to,
to dangerous competitors.
Well,
it's,
there were already our landlord,
so it's really,
you know,
what in the,
in the,
in the world of the future,
you know,
Inter,
the more we intermarried with the Chinese,
the more attractive our kids are going to be
and we're definitely gonna be eating better.
Right.
So how bad can it be?
Well,
it could be,
we'll give you one of those factory where,
cause it con comm that hits that suicide in that drunk and leap off the top of
the building.
You know,
they have those nets all around the building and keep people from killing
themselves.
It could get rough.
You've been in China?
No,
never been in a year to China.
Certain major chain hotels like Hilton Inn in New York.
It's like not the,
to my mind,
it's not the greatest hotel ever.
Okay.
You go to a Hilton in Shanghai,
it is fucking Luxe.
Okay.
Any,
any chain hotel in Shanghai or Beijing,
uh,
western chain hotel,
the level of excellence and technical superiority required or expected there is
so higher than in New York.
They just at that level,
the sort of people who,
who,
who would stay at one of these hotels in Shanghai are a lot richer and more
demanding than their equivalent in New York.
So lot of luxury and development that you see in places like China where you
know,
Jesus,
you know,
this is a dysfunctional government.
You would think it's fucking the communist for fuck's sake.
You know,
how come they got this great rail system?
how come there are hotels are nicer than ours.
How come Internet coverage is better?
How am I going to get us,
you know,
five bars on my cell phone,
anywhere in China and you know,
the deepest darkest valleys ass end of nowhere.
You know,
you,
you start to get this terrible.
I know I'm an,
I'm an American,
I'm a New Yorker.
We're the greatest country in the world.
I believe this.
Absolutely positively.
But you know,
at the end of the day it's like I just start thinking to myself,
if you know that,
you know,
the New York subway system,
to say that,
you know that in New York City subway system,
certainly not the best in the world,
it's idiotic to pretended it is.
You know,
well,
we held the crown somewhere 2030 whatever years ago it was,
whatever it was,
where we were,
the shining light of civilization.
It was in 1970 whatever year it was.
But we still have like the,
the,
the great,
the great weapons.
We are the most powerful nation on earth.
And I think largely based on,
on really the,
the danger of our culture.
You know,
people when introduced to rock and roll,
we'll eventually topple their governments.
I think it hasn't worked here but,
but abroad,
wait til Rick Perry gets an office.
You,
I think our,
our great cultural,
uh,
export has been,
you know,
a rock and roll rap music.
Uh,
clearly,
um,
it makes people want to do whatever it is they see.
They see,
they kind of want in one form or another.
They kind of want some form of that.
So in your experience and all of these under the countries and when you see all
these different,
um,
you know,
regimes getting toppled,
you don't think there's any American influence in these things happening?
I think we're that good.
Really.
You don't want to see,
I've,
I've actually,
I'm a CIA nerd.
I'm one of those like,
like I'm not a Gamer,
but I'm a guy who about 25 years ago,
started reading up on the Kennedy assassination,
gotten kept completely obsessed with that.
And then it just,
I'm one of these guys,
I read footnotes and a footnote leads me to another book to another book.
You know,
I disappeared down the rat hole for 10 years reading everything.
So I'm really,
did you ever invest evidence?
Uh,
yeah.
Um,
you know,
my,
my feeling is we're just,
if history has taught us anything,
and if you read all of the documents from all of the controversial periods of
CIA operations,
we just don't seem to be very good at these things.
And,
and everybody rats and writes a book about it immediately afterwards.
So if it went well,
you can be sure you'd be reading about or would have been lead to a magazine by
now.
You know,
it's,
I just,
I don't think that's so sad.
I don't think we're that good.
Uh,
and I,
I certainly don't think we have much of an appetite for controlling the
university.
I think we're,
we're,
we're doing it.
We seem to be,
we work very working very hard to hold the down.
MMM.
So you think this speculation about the CIA being involved,
like they're probably just very,
very peripherally involved.
And there's just shit happening no matter what their major CIA operations going
on right now without it,
without doubt.
But I think this notion that there's an office somewhere where the whole fate of
the world is sort of decided what countries are good,
it would fade over the next 10 years.
Uh,
we're just not that good and we're not definitely not that secure.
There's always three people know about something.
It's a greatest argument about the Kennedy's,
you know,
the nine 11 conspiracy theory,
idiots,
the Kennedy assassination,
uh,
looney tunes.
Um,
if basically in this country of three more than three people know about a thing,
one of them is going to be on the stand crying about it.
The other guy is going to be writing a book about it and maybe two guys will
keep their mouth shut.
I think today,
I don't think during the time of the Kennedy assassination,
it would have been that difficult to hide things.
I think,
uh,
things were less,
much less transparent back then were today you have a history.
That's what's great about history.
You know,
eventually if you're willing to wait around somebody [inaudible] to my view,
if you're willing to wait around or every boring grim detail will,
will eventually come out.
And,
and if you,
as in the Kennedy said,
so someone,
I don't know who said it,
they described the mafia theory as the halfway house for failed conspiracy
theorist.
It's like after you've decided to CIA didn't do it,
I did it.
It's like,
yeah,
okay,
well look,
it was the mafia.
You know,
and there's of course there's all this great evidence to support that theory,
but ultimately I'm of the Oswald got a lucky shot really flaring up.
I read best evidence and that's one of the reasons why I first started believing
that there was some sort of a conspiracy thing.
That was one of the,
one of the first things that I saw that made me really reconsider.
But later in life,
the thing that really got me was the Northwoods document.
If you never heard of that,
it's something that they drafted in the 1960 [inaudible] or 1960 where a 61 or
62 where Kennedy actually vetoed it.
And all the joint chiefs of Staff,
the Joint Chiefs of staff signed it.
And then we're going to have fake American,
uh,
terror attacks.
We're going to get a,
a plane.
They going to have a drone plane exploded and say a bunch of people died and
they were going to attack Guantanamo Bay and they were going to arm Cuban
friendlies to attack Guantanamo Bay.
We wanted to go to,
this was this,
was this a Cuban missile crisis era?
There were,
there were so many complete.
So this is what it,
to me,
what's interesting about Kennedy's assassination conspiracy.
It's,
there was so much it wacky shit going on around that time.
So much of it embarrassing.
Um,
criminal scary,
funny,
really silly going on at that time that in fact,
the least interesting thing about the entire,
you know,
big picture of the Kennedy assassination is the actual assassination itself
because what everybody else was up to at the time and covering up was just like
right out of a movie.
And the CIA get his meeting with Johnny Roselli and all these like mafia guys
that whack out Castro,
uh,
you know,
there,
there was just so much other embarrassing shit going on that in many ways those
stories and where they lead or a lot more entertaining and complex and,
and fun.
Then then a story of a guy,
you know,
shooting the president.
So if you believe that Lee Harvey Oswald acted alone,
what do you do about when you see the Oliver Stone movie?
Does that drive you fucking crazy?
It would have,
I would,
would've liked to fill in a lot better if they just stuck with the historical
record and he invented scenes and characters,
you know,
which I thought was as a,
as a,
as a Kennedy assassination plot and character does exist.
And there were just certain things we're just do mention that the garrison jury
was out for like 30 seconds.
He's mentioned the,
Jim Garrison is a man of many interesting local,
uh,
a man with an interesting paths,
let's put it that way.
Not,
uh,
did not,
not,
uh,
a reputation that was debatable.
Let's put it that way.
Um,
which is never good.
The case was bad.
I mean he put a lot of very interesting stuff together and there was an,
all of it was like fascinating and a lot of ways,
a lot of it was,
it was almost more interesting than the,
than that.
There wasn't,
I don't believe in the octopus theory.
I think you've had a lot of really interesting,
very spooky characters who've been doing a lot of really sinister,
uh,
an interesting shit for a long time.
Whether or not they were actually involved in the Kennedy assassination is
almost moot because they were up to some really other wacky stuff.
Did the magic bullet theory bother you at all?
I think if you talk,
and I have talked to people who served in combat for a long time,
the story of the buddy who gets around through the front of his helmet,
it travels around subcutaneously around the skull and it enters out the back
without hurting the guy.
Uh,
is it everybody's got shit happens,
shit happens.
I am.
I am willing to believe that magic bullet theory,
I would be willing to believe it except for the fact that they came up with it
because the guy got hit with a ricochet under the bridge.
And so they had to attribute everything to three shots.
And I was like,
ah,
that she just seems like fucking shifty.
Like I don't what what they're called.
But when you've eliminated all the other suspects,
uh,
you know,
you were left with the likely truth,
I think.
And I,
to my satisfaction and I've kind of eliminated the other suspects.
Woody Harrelson,
his dad didn't have any part of it.
Wasn't he like rumored to be one of the shooters?
You know,
wasn't that part of it's of course Howard Hunt was supposed to,
you know,
everybody's there.
You know,
it's like Mcdonald's is there.
Why is that so sexy?
Badly foot.
Loch ness,
monster,
Ua foes,
Kennedy the whole deal.
It's way more fun to think that Lee Harvey Oswald was a Pantsuit,
but remember,
he was a really interesting guy.
If you,
I think the book that got it close got it most right.
Uh,
was a work of fiction.
The Libra by Don Delillo or it,
it's really gets inside,
uh,
Oswald's head.
I mean,
Oswald was a guy who,
who his favorite show is a teenager was I led three lives about an undercover
FBI agent.
He was an intelligent,
he was a spy junkie in today's world.
He would have been a Gamer,
you know,
can win any game he wanted to be.
He,
he,
he was a guy who kind of wanted to,
to be,
uh,
to do big things and,
and he tried very hard.
He wanted to be super secret KGB agent.
He wanted to be super secret,
you know,
wanting to be a marine.
He probably volunteered to the FBI a couple of times.
He was just a guy who wanted to do something big.
Um,
so I don't have a problem buying it.
So you had no problem with the allegations of them fixing autopsy photos?
I have problems with all of it cause I was up lost in it for 10 years.
But the Kennedy family had very good reason to ask for,
you know,
the brain.
I mean he had Addison's disease and the implications of of Addison's disease,
uh,
towards the,
the Kennedy history were not favorable.
You know,
apparently,
I don't know but apparently it has been said that he had multiple bouts of
syphilis.
This is,
you know,
you don't want,
the family didn't want to press and people they want this part of the record.
There was a lot of syphilis.
Holla at your boy.
He took it,
it was worth it.
Amphetamines in large doses at that early,
it is pointed out who knows what.
He's really a,
he had a doctor,
Max Jacobson I believe,
I believe was the name.
He did have a doctor who would shoot him with the vitamin.
I think B12 and amphetamine according to one of the B mixed with speed.
That's how that dude was not uncommon at certain levels.
It was very,
you know,
a society thing to do back then.
It's a five hour energy drink.
That's what it is.
The 12 and a lot of people didn't even know there was,
who was the original doctor.
He was known as Dr Feelgood and that's where the name came from.
Dr I believe
it was doctor Max Jacobson night.
I don't know.
Legendary.
Wow.
Sort of doctor to the stars back in them Warhol and Kennedy's disease.
What did it have?
It was at a motor skill thing.
What is it that I don't,
but apparently there were,
uh,
there are in the symptoms,
the possible symptoms.
I think there can be emotional,
uh,
an emotional content to the disease.
So theoretically it could have affected his judgment.
It was,
it was unflattering.
I believe he was in a lot of,
this was a guide,
a lot of pain to supposedly,
right.
Yeah.
But back then you just didn't want to talk about these things.
And uh,
I think a lot of people,
uh,
ran around in circles covering things up for their own reasons and in fact most
of them had really terrible things to cover up that back then thing is really
fascinating when you think about it.
It's not that long ago.
I was,
I,
I was alive.
I remember being sent home from school when Kennedy was Ted Kennedy was killed.
And um,
but I,
I,
you know,
I go for the simple explanation much of the time.
It's the good move.
Um,
I keep the crazy open.
I opened the door for crazy because I've seen some things.
I leave it open.
I,
but I,
I agree with you.
Most of the time I go with a simple door with the crop circles and Ufo pose in
the loch ness monster and big foot.
Most of the time I go for the simple door.
People are full of Shit and that story sucks.
That's how I usually go.
But I leave the door for crazy open photos.
They just [inaudible].
It was very convincing.
Yeah.
But you know,
if I was going to be from a company that faked the moon landing you,
it definitely fake some pictures about it.
Fuck it.
You know what,
Richard Branson will be there like within the next five years.
Right.
He'll have a hotel on the moon,
no doubt about it.
Well,
he's definitely going to get people into space.
Apparently,
but it's going to be like for like $200,000 or something.
They've already built it.
We were driving through I think,
New Mexico or Arizona,
I forget where,
and we're in this tiny little town and said,
do you know him at the airport?
Airport?
They're not going out there because there's bill built a launch center.
He's built the launch center.
I think they're ready to go face.
They're selling tickets.
Your Janet already.
Totally,
yeah.
You'd have to totally imagine the view.
The view would be whatever view that you would get doing like high doses of
mushrooms in the dark by yourself probably wouldn't be as spectacular as looking
at the earth from 40,000 feet above it or you know more than that rather well,
whatever it is when you hit space,
but that would be good.
A hundred miles.
What does it,
what is it when you're 200 miles and Beta tested a little bit,
whatever this space shuttle is,
when you see that those photos,
when you get the full circle of the earth,
I mean that just,
it must be,
I would totally do that.
Life changing.
It's like wait a little steep.
Yeah.
On the travel channel.
Cough that up for a of DVD sales.
Get me,
that's happened season for us.
Yeah.
You,
you,
you supplement your income.
They'll doing um,
uh speakings too.
Right?
You go do this new found
respect for your profession.
I basically do stand up for a meeting.
I'm talking about a lot of issues that,
a lot of things,
but as you know,
cause we've worked a lot of the same theaters,
uh,
and I do about 40 of them a year.
Uh,
if you don't get a laugh every 60 seconds you're,
you've got a problem and I would think you would have a lot more liberty,
a lot more room for it.
Still.
It's,
you know,
it makes me want to laugh every 60 seconds and if they don't,
if not in 60 seconds,
the one that comes in two minutes,
we're going to be really fucking funny cause they had to wait for it.
And I've really learned a lot of things.
I mean I've done so many gigs now and I didn't understand.
I didn't know it.
I didn't realize I'm becoming a standup comic because I'm,
I am,
I'm starting it,
you know,
I still totally understand why,
comics,
so many comics drink and when you kill,
when you have a really good night,
I,
I come away like,
like kind of depressed by it really,
right.
Uh,
the,
the pressure of not knowing whether you're going to do well,
it's like being in a ski jump.
Like it's all decided,
you know,
how am I going to do on this jump?
You don't know when the,
when the thing's going,
beep,
beep and need before you head down the chute,
you just don't know.
You know,
you'd go and feeling really bad one night and you kill and then another night
you go in,
you're all pumped up.
You think you're 100%.
And it's just like you're out there like,
God,
that guy.
But,
but it's just weird.
Just like the bartender I was talking about before,
you start to learn,
you know where to lean.
You know what word to come down hard on how long the way,
and it is.
It is this terrible information that,
you know,
I feel guilty.
Why is it terrible?
Because it's been essentially it's manipulative and,
and when you're interviewed a lot,
or when you're doing the same routine a lot,
you know,
you start to,
someone will ask you off camera or offstage a question too.
You know,
something that you've just,
you're doing bit,
you know,
you slide into it and say,
well,
I was actually talking about this last night in the stage of the past leader.
But you're very humble.
You're very humble and the way you approach things.
And that's one of the reasons why you're such an interesting guy and one of the
reasons why your opinion is so respected.
But when you're,
uh,
when you're talking about this,
that it's what you're doing is all you're doing is getting the thought to them
as efficiently as possible and a method that you're already successful at.
It still what they need,
it's what they want to hear.
It's just,
even though you've already answered it exactly this way before,
you tend to think there's something wrong with that because it's not honest,
but you know the right way to say it,
it is the right tool to use.
I toured by basically had an evolving thing.
I started out talking and it became certain things work,
some things didn't.
But over time it would,
it would become,
it would an hour of solid material and he had the a at a material and you had to
be material be mature.
Like I'd go out and it's like nothing but fucking golfers and it's like,
oh shit.
You know?
Then I'd totally choked up.
I mean,
I've done casino,
I've done casinos were like belligerent,
you know,
drunks.
I mean I really,
how did you get started doing this?
I went out,
I went out on,
I was doing a lot of book tours and the books,
the bookstore crowds are getting bigger and bigger and so then they start
booking me in halls,
the bookstore,
you know,
so I'm basically,
I'm just looking to sell books.
I stand up there then and I talked for awhile about my book or I read from my
book and then,
and then,
you know,
I signed the book,
I started doing talks a while,
a book tour.
And then there are people who do this speaker's bureaus,
you know,
you want some macro economics,
macro,
macro economy.
So guided to talk about that are,
you know,
you need some Dick Jokes,
whatever,
you know,
the speakers bureau will have someone for you presumably,
um,
and,
and they just hook me up.
And I studied first I started doing a few corporate gigs and then theater
promoters to start a book in me.
So I just do theaters now as like if the local,
I'm sure we weren't so many of the same places,
I'm sure.
And it just suddenly I found myself,
well,
you know,
I've got an hour and then I do Q and a for another 45 minutes or until it's not
fun.
Not a poop jokes.
But you know,
those were the,
the buttons.
You know,
I've run up to this while I was enjoying your Carlos and then see a shit so much
because you know,
you run it,
you come up to this,
uh,
this point,
after two years,
he goes,
well,
I've done all the major cities now with this routine and it has been quoted in,
repeated in,
in,
uh,
in the local press.
And chances are if I said it in the first place live at some point earlier in my
career,
I may have written it or put it in the show.
So you reach this point,
it's like,
oh shit,
I need another completely new hour.
And that's hard.
It's very hard.
That is hard.
That's what plagiarism comes from.
And standup comedy,
a lot of it comes from desperation.
Yeah.
They just,
uh,
and then,
but then that guy's case,
it's a little different.
He's just fucking crazy.
But some of them,
they just need a new hour and they just get a little,
little funky.
You know,
it's just as funny if you say somebody else said it.
like I'll often say,
you know,
a Raymond Chandler said,
and then I'll say the thing and it just,
it was a really good fucking wine,
but that's why I used it.
You know,
spirit of it though is different.
The spirit of repeating someone in quoting them is very different than claiming
and for yourself.
And that's where it gets tricky.
You know,
standup comedy is a fucking weird art form,
man.
It's,
it's,
if there's any lies at all and then people are angry you,
you know,
if there's any bullshit in it and 30 faking it,
like that's not even his fucking name.
You mean his name is really not Larry the cable guy.
People will get mad,
man.
They'll get mad if you're,
if you're not honest about the whole package,
know they'll accept a character.
I mean,
I'm exaggerating obviously,
but they find out you don't really think the way you're talking on stage.
It's just bullshit.
Yeah.
I'll tell you though,
there was a casino I did to Harris Lake Tahoe and you know,
was that I never had a crowd
like this is going to do.
We're drunk gamblers.
They were already,
there were,
there were heckler.
I've never been heckled other than the occasional vegetarian,
but these were just drunk ass.
They would just heckling for them cause there was because they were trying to
do,
they were friendly hackers.
Right.
Uh,
but I just never,
I'd never contended with that man.
That is a,
that's a skill you got to learn quick.
Yeah.
Well I started out,
um,
doing really bad clubs.
I did a lot of,
I did strip clubs where I did a,
I guested at a rather mc to Jack and Jill Strip club in Woonsocket,
Rhode Island where the a guy would strip and a girl was trip.
I've done some horrible,
horrible places.
And when you do a lot of bars and a lot of like comedy nights and bars,
you're going to get hecklers.
Yeah,
no,
it's,
it's all good.
I mean,
it's fun.
It's fun.
It's exhausting.
It's really exhausting.
It's a rush for sure.
When you have the perfect word to say and that the heckler gets shut down and
everybody starts laughing.
Tell me that doesn't feel like the most awesome shit ever.
Yeah,
that's nice.
I get a bit.
Yeah.
Thank you very much for doing this,
man.
This was fun as hell I this all night.
I really enjoyed it,
man.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
This is a,
this has been a dream come true man.
Thank you very much because I'm a huge fan of your show and I geeked out when I
met you in Vegas,
so it was cool as fuck having you on the show.
Thank you to the flashlight for sponsoring the podcast.
If you go to Joe rogan.net,
click on the link for the flashlight and during the code name Rogan and you get
a 15% off the number one sex toy from,
and then you've got a bunch of new dates.
You can find them on twitter.com/joe Rogan and we're coming to Washington,
DC,
Denver,
Houston,
Ontario,
California,
and New Orleans.
Thank you everybody.
Thanks for tuning in and we'll see you next week.
Right.